I don't know what to do with this one.
I need to wait until the registers are here.
No, I just said make muted.
I'm not even up yet.
You don't know what to say make muted.
I say make muted.
I don't know what to say make muted.
I'm not even up yet.
Hello, I'm here.
I'm sorry that was my overly.
hello good morning good evening and good afternoon delayed by two hours I am
warning you know I'm hyper as shit okay because I ate we all the girls had a
nice little talk together some hyper is anything because we were having such a
freaking carry on I just want to say she be cotton bomb is live with a smart
a smarts warrior flavor then fucking gamble and I am very hyper we had so
much fun catching up and it was just like so fun and all our goals and the
girls and I've given them the green light so if they want to start achieving
their goals they can do it the money's there I'm putting like small little bits
of short advertisements the shorts were settled I have four short editors like
everything's coming together we flings I'm so happy everything's coming together
for my baby and it's just going amazing and we might have very exciting news
soon but this Saturday and our word debut highlights we're gonna go up on
Saturday okay Saturday which is two days away if you're from everywhere else
but if you're in the future like me it's one day away the game's a bit loud thank
you for telling me I watched back my mech assault stream oh my god the volume
adjustment was terrible in that game but we did it but we making out the house
with this one oh it was such a freaking so I told the girls that I lost my toe
in the great Vietnamese war at the nail salon and they were all laughing with me
and having a giggle and then I was telling them like oh I was constipated
so I kept repeating this thing where you go in a minute I'll give them an enema
I was fucking nasty but we're just having such a carry-on like joking like
AC was eating at one point and she's so cute when she eats she's like come down
yeah she sounds like a little cat it's just so cute and everyone laughed at the
yeah they're scared they need to laugh they feel forced to laugh and Amy is
getting two highlights of streams coming out soon TM I just I'm so excited I
inhaled my spit and I'm no choking on my own spit
oh the meeting was fantastic so Amy's getting two highlights coming out
Mercy has one coming out I've told the girls if you have a stream that you think
was just really fun and good please let me know I would order a highlight of it
and Emmys poppy playtime is getting a highlight and then her making a candy
with candy go my candy eye with her rat and I must alive it says air YouTube is
not receiving hello
am I still online
why is obvious telling me I'm not it's not receiving anything what can you guys
see me
I had to switch another way of you the stream yeah what the fuck obvious says
it can't even see me
hold on error YouTube is not receiving enough video to maintain smooth
streaming oh and now it changes to excellent condition all right so when I
catch you YouTube being sloppy and I when I catch you YouTube being sloppy hmm
okay we caught YouTube in 5k it says my condition is now excellent that's what I
thought okay I do apologize for the stream being two hours later but the
best time zone for everyone to come to to come and congregate and it was at my
usual time and this is going to be a bit of a shorter stream because again oh I
can't believe I'm doing work in the background but for those of you who are
signed up to my patreon you got early access to two celebration audios not the
alternative kind I recorded the honey tea script and a couple of hours ago
actually and I will be editing that I after I wake up but if you are on
patreon you got to listen to me burp and you got to listen to me clean your
ears hopefully the audios came out but hope you enjoyed it a funny one in a
kind of serious one yeah YouTube give that YouTube doctor and but yes I have
the next thing that's going to be uploaded is the patron audio which I owe
you and then a collab audio with someone I don't think I've revealed that I'm
collabing with them and but they're a will there's my hint for you
67 of the men to an average of 4.65 per minute what does that mean
barrel thank you for the five what does that mean 67 of the men and average of
4.65 per minute what does that mean what are you telling me sounds like you had
fun those boats mommy I bought your deodorant I can smell like you well the
reason why it says optionals because I don't always put deodorant on 67 of what
the numbers Mason what do they mean the numbers the number allegedly none of us
know what the numbers are you're being too obscure the number of my burps in the
audio no way you counted my fucking burps in the audio
my wine gives no reward money whoa we're not doing that right holey moley right
hold on red you blues yellow start with an extra 10 bucks wait what there's no
downside so then unlock a red dick a yellow dick a green dick a black dick a
red steak difficult whoa right with one with a blue dick which is why we've got
this little poker chip here a true bit lady belches like a lumberjack well I've
got you covered wait what did your father say about make so I'm not a chance to
talk to him I was working all night long I've upstream had a nap and then I
edited a secret thing for she be which you'll get to hear about very soon then
I edited two things for me and then I recorded for me and then I made notes
for the girls because we had a meeting and a recap of June and and then we
ended up hanging out for two hours and now I'm here so yeah I did not have time
to speak to my dad yet but my dad is getting here in a week and are we gonna
lose the house I just tuned in we might it's very plausible but we've completed
around with a dude a do-deck a blue deck we're gonna try yellow because it
already gives us such high economy seated run oh I thought it said speed run I
was like sure let's speed run this and but I would tell my dad my dad gets here
in a week so I'm probably just straight up show him that I don't think I said
anything to an appropriate in this room although he doesn't really do shit it
doubles your mom wait 14 times 2 is 28 a bag it I would never make $14 in this
run any like in this thing anyway so I'm actually gonna go next choose to up to
five tarot card yeah fuck it let's go in whoa whoa okay well that's a good start
are you also gonna play bachelor on the speed run say no he's choking right
delete two cards we can't be muckin about with stone card lean card a wild card
enhance two cards and a lucky card let's make her Queens lucky why not I don't
mind that let's make them lucky and if you aren't familiar with Baltrow don't
worry neither am I I got addicted after one game if you're familiar with poker
you may kind of recognize the structure of like aces and the pairs and a full
house is straight basically you guys may or may not have walked me through the
game a wild card turn it into a wild card and one minus hand size that's
fine we're going for it yeah I saw you like some comments I was like yes I also
interacted with some comments on YouTube as well and I've been meaning to get
around to it just to like that oh fuck this is a terrible hand I've been meaning
wait one oh one two three four we're shy of a flush I'm gonna go flush oh we got
flush let's go and I I what I wanna bank whoa who said that and yes I've been
trying to interact a bit more on YouTube on Twitter as well because all these
things kind of have been too impossible with what I'm juggling behind the scenes
but things are coming down I also got the first animation back and all the girls
reacted to it a sequel animated first for the video game and I think she's have
I think everyone was like what and I'm like yeah that's right that's what the
video game looks like and they're all like yeah so the plan is still June oh
my god these hands what are you giving me
we only have two more discards maybe we go for a oh wait we just did a flush with
spades and ended up with three of the spades wow we are not doing that hold on
discard and go for hat oh meh oh brother I think we're gonna have to go in
for another flush
go for doubles holy shit we're gonna lose how many and no no I've got three
hands fuck this I've got three hands sorry I've got more than enough right one
two three four oh what do you do nothing this is terrible holy crap the
minus thing was terrible June didn't you say July oh yeah July sorry not June
the other one the other one the other one please the other month that begins
with a jet no not January seeing your reply on Twitter to a tweet made me feel
like I was listening I am going to try and be more active on social media now
that I have more time I can start doing that stuff so please don't think I like
see all your comments I am so thankful for everyone that interacts with the post
fucking if you were on Twitter December right right how the fuck did you guys
say December all together is this an inside meme how did you guys sink to
December that's not a word am I freaking going crazy I'm losing it right we
don't even have this card so what all I can do is hike hard which is gonna give
me five and nothing more I really don't I don't want to but bro just give me a
diamond oh my god we actually lost maybe we lost we lost and we had so much
economy right go again holy crap we can't even get the freaking thing we
can actually share three plus hands the next time no okay let's not get greedy
for economy we already start with so much holy crap that minus one per thing
it begins literally the gamble begins I just want to warn you guys I truly and
wholeheartedly have no idea how long this stream is gonna go for you've been
worn do we have a royal shit we don't we didn't we do not have a royal shit we
have to double base 12 hours no and I have some exciting stuff that's cooking
I'm so sorry by the way for being so vague every time a royal shit literally
and I apologize so much for being so vague whenever I go on about something
it's because the plans are in motion and I'm like get why did I do that
what is that gonna take us over okay there we go I like it's because I can't
talk about it yeah but I want to tell you everything right three plus multiplier
for every Joker card that's just a straight-up dub first played face so
face or King Queen and Jack first played gives a multi and another one I don't
want to spend too much economy but at the same time I want to go all in I want
to go all in and get because of this Joker card what played car oh it's a
1.5 each King held in the hand gives a multiplier played cards with a heart
suit gives three wins scored and it has an overall multiplier and you come when
you come holy hell both of those are great three of a kind oh are we shaping
our deck yeah I think we're shaping our deck 12 multiplayer if a three of a
kind I think we have shaped our run we do not need what we are who are you
12 multiplayer 1.5 12 if it's a three of a kind and if it has a face on it okay
okay okay well we already have a royal flush which is fine let's go for that
face card yeah fantastic cheese a suit plus three of a kind is that viable not
quite but we're here to do it one plus hand size curious one plus hand size
that would enable us to get our three of a kind more I know this has a chance to
be destroyed I don't want to spend economy now to get destroyed so I'm
gonna buy and then we want to enhance three of a kind I know I'm spending
economy I know I know right three of a kind has now been maxed up so it's also
now extra potent thank you to Zanny Joker not to be confused with the wild
cow all spade cards are debuff thank goodness I'm hearts then right what are
we looking at we've got fuck all we wait we really have nothing we don't even
have a flush with one double and that's it I want to get rid of those I want to
go for a flush to be honest or should I rule for an eight yeah yeah I think you're
right rule for an eight right okay but what what if you gave us an eight or a
nine or a four for fuck's sake what throw those away so what happens if I do
you oh fucking one-on-one beautiful we love to see it shadow wizards when you
get right we're gonna oh we might want this because that's what saved me last
time it did is what saved me last time not really fuss for these I think I'm
gonna keep my economy I want to grab on to you because this saved us in our only
win that we've had so far upgrade four of a kind by three levels I'm not got four
of a kind I'm not playing for four of a kind she's cracked at Gamble I'm gonna go
for a cumulative Nimbus we're gonna get an extra dollar for this round and then
next round we'll see what it comes a bit oh dear I'm struggling to get my
threes in I it pains me to throw away it pains me to throw them away though
sorry one two bro just give me the nine I literally only need it like I only need
a nine or a K are another away an ace yeah okay this game has jokes thank you
right let's see if we do the triple strongy teaching us again but no don't
say such things she be caught and bum is live with ASMR please do check out her
ASMR because I'm just ranting like a lunatic about Gamble okay we're now
getting three interests if we hold on are we about to go against the boss
I need to buy this now create up to two random tarot cards oh it's a mega
celestial pack mother we are now addicted to Gamble yeah the strongy
bubbles never bust in trust this dummy you should play full house they contain
three pairs three of kind oh I didn't can I didn't even consider that and full
house would we'd take this into account but you're absolutely right right for
safety reasons
that have another round invest in strong coin new crypto currency just drop you
have to get a voucher now next battle is gone ah okay thank you refling I thought
that too I thought that too we're gonna get a dollar interest and I'm like
we just no I'll take the dollar interest it'll accumulate don't be greedy I'll
behave I'll behave okay a mega standard pack I'm not really fussed for that okay
let's see what we've got what's what we've got double evades we've got tons of
doubles I need that half written one I'm sorry there's so many doubles kind of
multiplayer whoa the multiplayer is so counted anyway I don't even need to fish
for triples when blind is selected gain three hands and lose all this hard a
celestial pack
actually here we're it doesn't matter if we spend the four we're only getting
two dollars interest anyway we're getting we're only getting two dollars
DJ and doker and Uranus a straight and a high high card as straight I feel like
might actually come up more than well two pairs is kind of a Hail Mary for us so
I'll go Uranus he's a troublemaker right next round all diamond cards are
debuff that's fine I don't really think that's a problem right we did just
double up pairs a upgrade pair so we're gonna send it and we unlock to Joker
don't mind me don't mind me at all okay and we got our interest that's
fantastic so now what we got foil holographic cars appear twice as often
what are you when small blind or big blind is selected gain a multiplier
destroy a Joker right around Joker we win in the house pack with this one the
Joker gets more money through more hands oops wait what over wait what this one
this one not this Joker oh sorry the last one we ain't gonna live on the
streets the criminal one the one from before all my apologies I was familiar
with it I'm gonna redeem the foil holographic so we're back down to two
economy pair round but that's fine that's fine we're still cooking discard
$1 pair use card what will give you 12 bucks sorry I don't understand if I
don't understand I'm not doing it because it doesn't make sense to me I'm gonna
need this half Joker because let's be honest I'm just playing doubles again
the triples really do not come out to play much a $5 orange net four times
multiplayer every six hands played wait hold on hold on I want rid of you then
four times multiplayer wait five remaining it says remaining it paid you
for every discard this one shit that was a really good one then I apologize I did
not read that properly but look this is why we learning on screen I was wondering
if I should record solo runs of me playing this and upload it as actual
like video content like oh this is the best one I've had but I don't know if
that's weird you can triple to occur so you play so you play five hands with
one times and one oh no okay that's not for me
spectral card spectral card I have no idea what's a spectral card is that the
one where it turns the card gold in that and no that would actually can kill
fee free to make some videos yes some people try it you know what try I will
try it what's going on here creates the planet card for final player poker hand
it's been held okay that's what we'll see create a tarot card if discarded I will
shove a discard because it's easier to discard than have it sitting on your hand
rotten away okay I like it I like it next round let's go what are you three
plus size decreased level of played poker hand but I think we're fine she's
famous last word right I know I keep playing doubles but it's right I'll you
know what fuck it I'll discard a bunch and we'll try and get a tenner jack are
you fucking I'm being trolled right now by this game give me a triple right fuck
you you're going out the window so what are you enhances to bonus card sure let's
make the aces bonus cards why not yes bonus card what do you do extra chips
play hands I can game is actually truly that is a pretty good tarot though I'll
take it okay we've got nine dollar he does sell this card to disable the current
boss blind wow that's unique each played ten or four gives an extra and for
molecular when I wonder if you had straights this would be a very strong
one okay these are tarot cards pack I'm not really can run so let me finish my
honey to you strongy for gore the full house I did a sorry I'm speedrun this
decreased level of played poker hand I think we're fine yes fine twos fours
we've got our first triple full house I remembered the full house I remembered
refling okay well we're already 50% of the way there and we didn't even do
anything yet so we'll just do doble v's for now play hands god that really knocked
down the value okay but we're fine we're absolutely fine we are smooth sailing
and before we actually have a successful run as good man and we got live in our
10 multiplier played face cards have a one-in-two chance to give money as well
fuck that we are grabbing you so what sell juggler has mummy gamb at the house
yet careful with this one we'll get that oh yeah okay bye hello and you come
convert up to three selected cards the space planet cards appear more
frequently in the shop mmm I want to invest in planets if I'm being honest I
think we're gonna need to start doing it before we get in trouble so a flush give
me a flush no not flush sorry a full house is why one full house yes give me
that and then give me give me give me you give me you give me you and then four
of a kind is so rare four of a kind is so rare right we've completely gone in
on even though three of a click kind yeah yeah yeah this is should I invest in
planet cards should I should you like Nicki Minaj what that's such a very
specific question what happens do you want me to start rapping this one's for
the boys with a booming system top-down AC with a cooling system when they come
up in the club I'd be blazing up they got stacks on stacks on decks like they
save it up is that what you wanted to hear to be honest
okay I finished my tea I actually finished my tea and I'm hydrated think
of the economy I know it's in shambles because people are paying off their debts
in society is built for you to be indebted and sleep planet cards appear more
frequently played face cards have a chance to give me money
I'll take it you have to tell me twice I'm wondering oh right if I do this I get
$3 if I do this I get $1 in interest which is really greedy but I kind of
want planets or what saved the run I'm sorry but mummy's gambling after
defeating the boss gain 25 extra hmm next-based addition there's a free thing
a extra large blind soon made the strongy man come to bring us reef flings soon
made the strongy man come to bring us reef flings peeing tongue I don't have a
managed to figure out what you were putting there strongy I forgot to
mention that girlfriend also hit different did you like the girlfriend I
thought it was so bad sounded just like her honestly I'm actually Nicki Minaj
for real for real you need to store money because there's a 20k wall and all
that's why I'm trying to invest in planets because the bonus that planets
give is just insane I only have full house and three of a kind levelled up
I'm needing to invest in planets oh I'm needing to invest in planets
just skip for 25 bucks and say fuck it oh you need the money right I need the
money okay you have to tell me twice I'm a good girl I need the money I need the
money I'm wondering that I try and get a fucking what do you do if I play a face
card I have a chance to get money right go for it played face cards have a one
and two chance to give money when scored right give me money now do it yes it
popped we got an extra two dollars let's go let's go it popped it popped I heard
it went okay because of that factor oh we're actually went off from a flush you
know that I really don't want to throw these away but I want to play face
card okay okay okay pop again do it oh we go six doll hairs because so much
bonus wait and the bonus counted because we've reached the bonus so we're
gonna when blind is like to destroy Joker to the right and permanently add
double it's that's a member getting paid please straw me moan quietly I have you
on speakers oh there we go nice and quiet the gulping in the burps made me
think of Emmys Pandario I listened to that for the first time yesterday I was
actually too scared to listen to it and I listened to it and I was like oh wow
I actually don't mind we're losing her to the gambon yeah move the polychrome
Joker to the far right it will give you most mullies in that position see I
don't know how you guys know that but it's so good you guys are so smart right
this is useless we're gonna keep economy keep economy choose one of three
playing cards to add to the deck oh wait hold on what a waste of fucking money
were you next base it becomes a polychrome 1.5 multi what the sigma first
played face card gives to multi I might skip in order to get this 1.5 multi one
because you're starting to you're starting to grind my gears and you're
not really doing too much I can't reroll the boss if I decide to 20k wall is a
risk are you sure I feel like I make so much money I'm like doing this in one
round I have four hands personally played up to purple steak with a few
deck oh do we do it jokers activate left to right yeah if you wanted the audio
it'd be more realistic there'd be a kiss if you need gulp and burping
photograph but can't photograph is kind of weak yeah if you skip you go straight
to the boss though purple steak is doable if you've got the good jokers
you will have to fish for the full house to save the wall shit okay what does it
mean right I'm gonna trade out this for a 1.5 multiplier I can't play my last
town my my last hand so what do you play
okay that was that was three
we're gonna try and get faces up in here I'm fucking kidding me
am I fucking up I think I'm fucking up
oh I'm getting fucking trolled shit shit oh no refunds what have I done
mummies are we oh no I can only do a fucking ace card ace card and like throw
this stuff away
oh mummies not very smart oh mummies not very smart darlin oh mummies very mummies
very silly so I can't play high card I can't play a double I can't play a quote
I really do what fucking triple and throw this shit away oh wait well when
five consecutive rounds by playing only one hand okay tuples hand okay mummy
through cuz she got too cocky we lost the house the house is gone right I'm
sure we can win with a yellow dick it literally gives so much economy at the
start gives a free mega arco pack initially initial cards and booster packs
are free in the next shot don't have to don't have to tell me twice honestly
we're always going on here lucky cards increase the rank gives a total sale
but oh wait no that's alright a gold card three dollars if this card is held in
the round now let's put some lockdown even if you lose the house I'll still
have the refunds exactly that's the main thing right what do you do let's just
shove on a gold card then oh wait what gives the tools no stop I keep getting
confused and think temperance is the other one increase the rank of cards
three bucks if it's held in your hand at the end of the round sure let's just
have on a wee one devil the two oh my god we thought the same thing are we all
diamond cards are debuff that's fine right
can you give me anything what's going on wave streamer luck gone right we'll
play a double and get rid of all this shit where is my streamer luck
hello I'm not a streamer luck wait hold on man idea flush flush no oh my god the
house is literally gone we'll be here for you through rain or sleet or slag
literally what did you call me I have a double I guess I can play the double
it's not gonna be very effective but it's the best I can do I'm gonna lose
brah I think I'm actually gonna live what should I go for a flush maybe I
think I should go for a heart's flush you know that I'm going for hearts flush
okay that's what we want to see one two three four five hearts flushes go I lost
again I lost again I have one more discard buying gonna do none I freaking
suck at this game brah I lost again go again go again go again get again
double skip is the hardest start I know but it's free boy the cardboard box
isn't that bad guys like you guys look I'll get us out of the cardboard box see
I lost all my money because cardboard box but now but now I'll do it you know
hold on sorry definitely worth skipping for those two nah I'm with you on that
one right let's see can I get a flush nine eight seven six five four three two
one zero okay okay okay I'm seeing some there's some form of streamer luck
coming through I should roll for a heart I want to kind of keep these I want to
roll for a heart though it was risky and it didn't pay off but it's fine because
we can play doubles it was risky it was risky I admit it okay we're gonna get
two extra for economy at $14 which is juicy so I still pack always contain a
planet as well 10 multiplayer if to pair well I know what kind of run word
where do we ink in the box I need some privacy you ink on me of course hello
what do you need privacy for I mean technically you're covered you know your
tentacle gets hidden you know right we're definitely not letting this Joker go
waste I a celestial pack will also contain a planet which is absolutely
insane insane I want it mummy wants it okay I've never bought that before sorry
I'm going all out I'm going all out fuck the economy I'm going into debt right
okay four bucks if you know another would flush why are they so bad when
small blind or biggest like to gain a multiplier and destroy a random Joker
no earn four bucks if I mean I'm gonna pick it up because I'd rather just sell
it then skip then what pick up pick up the jumbo pack I can't even pick it up
I'm too poor right we're gonna purposely earn four bucks if the poker hand is a
flush poker hand changes at end of round what what are you saying right we're
just gonna take the $1 interest I have no idea what it was asking me I was
asking for something but I'm not smart enough save the money on interest yeah
you better I know I should save I know I know but I get I get greedy okay I don't
know why like digital like not real gamble is so fun because I'm like I'm
not angry when I lose because I'm it's I'm not losing money so I'm not mad like
I don't I don't know if you guys have ever actually I can ask you if you've ever
gambled hold on hold on let me ask you right now I'm gonna I'm gonna do a
little poll and see if you guys have ever gambled before I'm gonna see hold on
you're gonna hear my voice twice oh no it's muted you guys better watch that
mercy modi sure I'm gonna get married wait whoa why did it delete the message
but it didn't unpin it whatever have you oh wait that's not a freaking poll
don't look I made a mistake I made a mistake don't look don't look that's
embarrassing I didn't I was typing in the open chat have you ever done have you
don't like don't laugh have you ever done real gambler before yes but only Teehee
fun no not not for me yes I have a problem
I'm asking if the reeflings have actually gambled in real life that I don't
think I've ever gambled in real
let's see what the reeflings are coming in with a vote so the votes are coming
flying in we have 22 votes already the reeflings couldn't give less of a shit
about Gambo they all won strong it is set on their face that's the way I like
to see I like to see the competition high we've got yes Teehee oh it's
switching from yes Teehee but only for fun oh no sitting on the face takes the
lead I repeat ladies and gentlemen sit on the face takes the lead I answered
before I saw the last option I was put a meme at the last option for future
reference okay okay okay someone said 7% says yes I have a problem reeflings
are you okay I need to give you an intervention because I will answers the
top one but you gave me a chance so you know I had to pick the last one yeah
okay if there is actually anyone that struggles with gamble please don't watch
the stream this is not me endorsing it that's shut up in me damn I overlooked
the last option get wrecked okay now that I have distracted you all from okay
so I get 10 multiplier if I hit this oh two pair oh for goodness sake oh there's
a bubble in my throat oh two pairs and I just gambled it away how can one person
suck so much at reading basic instructions like I'm not being funny but
as if I just throw away a nine only for the game to give me a nine oh right
there you are now do it okay there we go geez freaking twat honestly I like
smack myself on the face oh okay hold on we've got complimentary I know we're
poor but we've got complimentary that compliments so well okay choose one of
planets okay I'm sorry I'm just selling everything give me two pair
okay so as we're in a good place one-hand size doesn't matter give me a
double pair we've got tens what just throw everything away in hopes of a
double oh that's risky oh it paid off it paid off mummy's getting the house back
refunds don't worry mummy's getting the house back oh oh mummy's getting the
house back don't you worry right that's a straight three no we're not paying no
you should have showed up last game you're too late now hi to it no we're
not doing straights no we're not doing that raise the cap on interest earned we
can't buy it but we're gonna save do you love Uranus I don't know reeflings do you
love the planet remember full house also gets you a full bonus okay I need to
keep that in mind oh upgrades two pairs by three levels hello yes what are you
next space edition shop is a free and it's a negative and it gives me an
extra Joker slot sorry that's so valuable I'm so sorry right extra large
blind I doubt it me give me two and you're done you're a double the rest of
you aren't double so you're all getting thrown in the bin okay I need doubles of
anything really shit no not like this come on give me the double oh it worked
oh my god it paid off whoa wait this forum no wait no dude yeah okay sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry I
gave you all a heart attack there my brain was like huh wait we didn't even
win oh this isn't leveled up enough holy crap right we're about to level up again
though we're about to level up again there we go six multiplier we're getting
there we're leveling this up and we've got it so early okay yes okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay one hand each round absolutely not four times every six
hand and a Joker so it's free so sure come aboard arena no what was that thing
I picked up about sure what were you celestial packs always contain a
planet card for your most played poker hand that's so OP I must remember to buy
celestial it packs I'm not doing one takeaway hand I'm too nervous for that I
actually want something better so I'm going to keep my economy for this round
it's free it is the free negative I remember golden Joker is pretty good to
have early on earn an extra four dollars wait he'll pay wait hold on he'll pay
himself off after two rounds
he'll instantly pay himself off sorry you're absolutely right he'll pay himself
off he'll pay himself off doubles your money well that would only give me 20
I make 20 bucks I make $10 per game I don't think so I think this would
actually give me more how do I know reward is three dollars oh no don't
skip because I've got the Joker now thank you thank you sorry sorry just getting
used to it hold on hold on let me use my brain right you can all get to you
I do want to level this up like way more no don't do this to me no don't do
okay there we go there we go level up level up what are you six multiplier
guess what give me that eight multiplier oh oh we're leveling him up and we got
an extra four dollars oh wow okay we got 12 bucks so yeah we should have done that
a flash don't care the stroke or kings gains four tip if the hand is exactly
four cards I mean you're not you're not awful you're not the best buy him this
little guy buy a little the stroke or contains four tips it will grow with the
pairs okay and he come and you can I'm gonna go gamble on the celestial pack
because I love a bit of urin anus I don't know about you but I love a good
bit of well I do anyway don't worry if you don't enjoy urinus I will make you
enjoy it very soon oh decrease level played poker hand that's fine a free
poly and a 1.5 to pay really is a pro run is that how you say urinus in scots
no it on YouTube type in British TV show urinate Uranus gag and it's this
presenter and the questions like what's the seventh planet and in the solar
system and they had been giggling about it all day long and my dad and my mom
absolutely I love the clip so much and she's like cracking up so it's like
it's like daytime TV show and she's like is it Neptune is it Jupiter or is it
which is why I say a ruin it in this I know it's Uranus and there's an argument
for and against I want to skip and have faith the polychrome is gonna is gonna
come in okay I have faith any faith watchers hmm okay okay you are all
getting to fuck I've already got first double her pants looking right 8 on our
pants and let's play what are you gonna do a little guy you got upgraded oh whoa
that did not actually meet the requirements curious got a win for the
polychrome yeah strong I want to play with your urinus play a straight oh
shit did I miss it wait no no no no straights aren't effective for me wait
oh sorry you're playing sorry you said you meant play a straight right now I
will I'm so sorry sorry sorry you meant please straight right now I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'll see it stream delayed but there's there's no stream delay I'm
sorry I love him he's so good okay okay okay who are you playing cards can be
purchased from the shop no the Hyrofrench oh yeah let's use okay we can't use
you yet but that's fine choose one tarot card yes enhances to multi-card stay
right up to two random planet card oh Emperor no way we got Emperor that's
fantastic no oh shit I was full I was full oh no I made a mistake you know what
it is what it is I ain't gonna be mad right playing cards could I what would I
do if I had more playing cards I don't know if that would mess up my odds a bit
more you know that this voucher is bad yeah I wasn't really sure about that I'm
sorry I just straight up bomb it is there I don't know if you could tell
there right fuck it we're gonna even get full house no wait level five oh my
gosh oh my gosh gives a mega standard pack choose two of the five playing
cards that's the deck now I'm fine strongy you realize it's guaranteed this
less your pack gives you an interest right shit did I just mess up I need to
level up the pants more we're currently on 10 multiplier and we do have a two
here so I'm gonna throw away a two I'm not gonna like this we got a double we
got a double right pants are now on 10 right now oh wait oh sorry sorry I should
use the higher higher higher fan use bonus cards sure go for it do you do
extra chips that's fine and hearts sure doesn't really make a difference of
things our hearts I'm not really doing flushes but I want to use it so my
little a polychrome oh my god that's so satisfying on the eyes I'm gonna sneeze
I'm gonna sneeze yeah it's freaking stuck in my nose and it goes away of course
because I meant oh 10,000 for that cheeky bonus oh my god 12k two
interest per five mat yeah yeah this golden joker is helping me recover
economy I know I'm being greedy I can't help it right spec troll no possibly
uh potentially yeah fuck it and then you wait you first cuz you give me a
planet creates a random rare joker sets money to zero no converts all cards in
hand to a single random rank no wait these are all full
are these terrible or a mammoth's understanding skip skip yeah I was
gonna say I'm not sure about that right anyway we're gonna buy a tarot
that would be choose choose the tarot as well okay lovely lovely lovely
oh we'll fortune destroy our gold card if I lose this I owe you one one audio on
Twitter if I lose this a little late but I'm glad your back little
hi Mona thank you for the five a little late but I'm glad your back little
seaweed oh my god is that my nickname are you guys gonna call me little seaweed
oh that's such a cute fucking name what the shot that's so cute my heart can you
guys call me my little you you guys call me little seaweed because I like
flowers but I'm I'm a water type vtuber like as if I'm a Pokemon I'm a water
type vtuber oh thank you thank you for becoming a member to me and I really
appreciate that oh my god that's the cutest nickname ever I like cuddles is
such a cute nickname so seaweed I love little seaweed little seaweed yeah there
she's actually gambling audio is now too the house is gone I need to do
something anything okay next round I'm gonna no I can't do it for ever kind
of discards to random cards pair hand play that's fine right clubs clubs
clubs sure everyone you become a club you become a club you all become
clubs okay we're about five so one two three four however the pants looking
pants are on 12 multiplayer looking good looking good we're getting upgrades
as well we're getting up we did it oh we're doing a wild card nope maybe maybe
a cheeky eight dollars and a three wait why are you vibran oh it's active okay
you should move the daily card to the far right thank you for daily daily daily
card to the far right thank you you guys are too good at this game honestly the
gambas made its way to real life and to win because it's a one-time five rather
than a plus three tarot hmm cheeky eight but that card needs release clearly
that's what you guys are like well wintering double celestial for double
okay
no way
oh wait wait did you guys say it's always gonna show Uranus now wait am I being
pepega and celebrating thinking my luck's really good but it's always gonna
show oh it's always gonna show Uranus I keep us here's me celebrating like yes
yes streamer look we're doing it guys we're doing it no it's guaranteed you
dumb dumb I'm sorry I'm very special but I'm a happy kind of special wild card
um okay next round let's go I don't really need you and I don't need you
right because you're not particularly the best okay what do you do you enhance
into a wild card we do have fives shove you into a wild card okay lovely what do
you do can be used as any suit as well I'm interested unfortunately I'm gonna
toss everything out the window and we've got a wild car or what are you 14
multiplier don't mind that and you're gonna
oh
50 50 this thing was ready to pop off
a full house technically yeah the stroke again the multiplier every time a
plane card is added to your deck planets appear two times more frequently in the
shop as well sure oh my god this is getting outrageous is there a max level
there can be is there no maybe maybe maybe there's a max level about your badge
you're very special 10k before I literally 50k cuz this pot this popped
off as well or special little cephalopods oh I assume you can go beyond 10 oh no
you can
are you squiddin me right now wow quick you I think right you hover your mouse
over your deck it'll tell you what cards are left in the deck if you're hunting
pairs knowing whether there's three to two or zero left will help you out
okay thank you for the 10 internet battle file effective total due to Joker
blind card right okay I think I'm oh that's right cuz I turned loads of things
into different things well it's not really caring today okay that makes it I
was like oh how is there 15 hearts I changed stuff around okay hover not
click hover have a hover of their wild card you can go past level 10 oh my god
stop it wait so this is good or this is bad you guys weren't really feeling the
merchants planet or planet merchant my apologies all the way around a full house
I'm just going in for pairs currently at 16 that voucher isn't good your packs are
much better okay okay okay let's go again re-rolls and next shopper no
we're voting on one pair which is good I mean we could just play a flush for the
hell of it if I don't want to mess it up so we'll just throw it
oh we got 16 16 on the truzos what are you your sex I need more turrets
currently 16 chips in addition okay oh my goodness oh my goodness we're
upgrading along the way 90 yeah 19 wow if you click it shows the deck
distribution Philly but hovering much easier I'll hover over your stuff right
not that what are you one plus multiply for each empty Joker slot no that's
terrible maybe at the start of the game but no mega celestial let's go let's go
let's go right a pair a full house a full house is the next best thing we can
upgrade so we will yes we'll do okay and then we'll do a celestial oh my gosh
what the more the odds in this showed up again oh let's see what you look like
now 240 times 13 that's like a big number that's 2000 to 400 and then the
30 is like an extra what 27 something 2700 something around that area okay
we're gonna grab the turret we love you to have it around here yes we do
convert into space initial cards and booster packs are it's tempting oh no
repeat hands types in the round okay it's not worth it 3k before Joker a
little over 2k yeah last year level the pants okay understood level the pants
you to get to work in level these pants on 18 multiply go upgrade upgrade
upgrade everyone's getting an upgrade we got 20,000 in the first oh no I didn't
use my turret card that's okay we can use it in the boss fight I'm just no okay
bye no I can't use it right now the game you the game you I was a silly
sausage and punished me for it why can't I be a silly sausage in peace what
do you do use to a turret card immediately okay but what happens if we
did the wheel of fortune on okay an exchange an exchange for wearing a
plug during a string no I'm joking but what but what if come on use your cards
now oh I will use my cards now yay and then three spades you're not spade
you're not spade you're not spade use your old space okay and then and then a
wheel let's go for it come on I own one stream where I'm full no come on I can't
win it's a one in four Uranus get in here oh my god Uranus is getting out
control hold on wait two six say by 14 I think this is getting like wildly out
control this run okay no repeat at hand type so make it count what do you do a
multiplier while it stays in hand okay so we'll do our first double that's fine
play hands that's fine that's not problem and then we'll see where that break
takes us up oh we did it we didn't even need to like do anything oh my truth
there's the ROP play cards as a spade now four of a cane not really permanently
give a yes I would absolutely adore that especially when we get in trouble and a
tarot card I didn't use that again classic me never use my fucking tarot card
what do you do take select two cards and convert the left into the right I don't
know what to convert convert the two of heart convert the two of heart into a
steel diamond oh yeah baby and I got 10 for that okay what we're looking at here
well gold card spades double money which would take me up to 28 another steel
card or a wild card some of this temperance turn a second one into a
steel nope it's gain 20 not double money oh it gives the total cell value
currently 20 oh that's quite a lot to mess around with and I'll get a lot of
interest I think I'm gonna go with the 20 because then I can get more interest
because it goes up to 50 my max ceiling is 50 hermit is double the money yes
temperance and hermit I keep I keep messing up right we'll do money we'll do
money classic women moment I mean we might as well muck with the booster pack
cuz this isn't gonna hit the thing sure absolutely in you come right don't
really need any of that four of a kind I don't think I'm ever gonna roll that I'd
rather just save it no we do not need free re-rolls at the shop but we are
thankful for your offer nonetheless we're gonna level up again our lovely 22
multiplier so 24 oh you can't even be doing this to me game no wonder I'm
addicted sorry but no wonder I'm actually addicted I'm sorry but no wonder
me one oh instead of the golden Joker maybe him I don't know I'll buy a house
hacker great card yeah so I'll get rid of golden Joker because we're kind of the
point where economy isn't really an issue so we'll get rid of our beloved
you have done is a great service golden Joker you have made us richer than our
wildest dreams I do appreciate you and to top off you're giving me three bucks
back I cannot thank you for yourself service enough and you're doing
fantastic sweet keep it up and we are gonna just upgrade full house not that
it's a waste I'm not really fussed for a playing card
hey we just go next go next keep a high we're just winning 24 multiplier get up
there we're like sticking ahead perfectly of what the round is asking
we're not playing straight and we're not doing odds so we don't really need
anything at all
no I'm happy we're currently also level in these two up in combination with each
other you already won big number yeah I do not think we need odd Todd odd Todd
you did fantastic for us in another round but my little seaweed you need to move
the dev deli card to the right again oh thank you thank you sorry sorry sorry
special needs but the good kind the daily card is a little bit excited look
that's you replaying when I talk to you in my try hard boys okay next round all
diamond cards are debuffed you think that's gonna stop me you think wait
hold on we didn't roll a perfect we didn't actually roll a perfect thingy
two doubles I can't believe it right even though that's gonna be debuffed we
still are gonna get our pair multiplier in I'm just going for okay I know I can't
believe I didn't roll into perfect doubles every single time yeah we got our
upgrades that's the main thing we get our upgrades this is insane him coming in
as well oh my gosh oh my gosh whoa wait hold on 10 multi and for multi I think
card sharp is getting out I think card sharp has gone for our straight-up
Joker holographic agreed 14 plus is better than hacker okay and you've done
fantastic for us for that one round card sharp you really have the hackers better
hard sharp is better wait real wait real this is better he does 10 multi he's
holographic he does 10 multiply it multipliers your entire Molly tool how do
you guys know this stuff I'm too confused and dumb to understand it three times
is better than 14 plus oh I've just discovered that the game registers the
pluses and the times differently and it's not all the same I've just discovered
that the pluses and the times are not the same holy moly holy moly dumb ass oh my
god there's no way I could be this done okay yes I agree hacker or sharp card I
like how you call him hacker man I like he's got me nicknamed yes I agree with
oh what a lovely day to see you on oh what a shocker me to see you here and
you come right warwick 300 times 16 right add a zero at the end and then times
that by 6 3 3 times 6 is 12 so 1200 pair fucking go and that's not even with
a multiplier okay next round let's go I do not need that were you cards played
previously this okay I'm getting nervous I'm gonna shake you what does that mean
I'm in trouble I'm in trouble almost 5k before joker gives 5 bucks pairs good do
I want a size of 3 is the plurals is the plural of Uranus urani I don't know
maybe I think I've got a card ranked 20 no idea what the limit is we bet we beat
we bet to win in one hand it means finish hands in this few cards okay
that's fine then let's go for it let me level up come on let me level up my
pair of pantyloons come on mommy needs a new pair of pantyloons oh mommy needs a
new pair of pantyloons getting deep deep deep deep boom upgrade upgrade upgrade
people how much 43 don't mind if I do you don't mind if I do we're now at 30 I do
need tarot cards tarot cards are hidden from me okay well speaking of tarot
cards hidden from you oh what do we get bonus card bonus card okay let's do
bonus cards bonus bonus to yes bonus card okay you did get a little bit love
there maybe we can get a tarot card one what do you do a gold card and a gold
seal five chips three if this card is held in the hand or three when the card
is played wait gold card and sealed to the exact thing um strongy out here like
get upgrade get upgraded get upgraded get upgraded yeah you like that yeah we
get an upgrade so here okay let me hydrate hydration check my little
leaflings we've been playing for a hot second okay okay okay I need to pick
something up we're so far up here right no no strongy the card you get paid
whether you use it or not I don't need you oh I got a joker card unlocked I
like that the game shows that sorry I'm a bit too big I mean I could be right in
the chat okay no I'm coming back here okay well I get distracted with it when
it comes to licking you and we don't want to reroll we're not over 50 yet so
we're not gonna skip we don't need to skip we're we're big boys and girls but
and the game loves me what can I say talk about hashtag streamer luck and we
got money oh wow we actually have to play another round well I'm shocked and not
amused okay give me come on give me more celestial packs I want to pair to be
like level of 164 in a round what one in oh god that's right to get interest like
cuz I bought that interesting oh my god and we got two tarot cards and we got
celestial jumbo packs I can't take it oh I'm good freaking you know what I'm
gonna do but I'm fucking addicted and I can't stop I love this game thank you
for carrying me through the game this is amazing if we reroll no we don't because
I spent all okay next time we spend more big money big ink ink everywhere
exactly right okay let's use these get spades you're a spade so get spaded get
spaded okay then your diamonds get diamonds get diamonds get diamonds oh yeah
we're 14 plus okay do we have you you you you you play I want you to stay in my
hand so you play and then plus 23 24 sorry 36 I cannot do numbers sorry I got
that thing with numbers it's like the voices in my head they tell me to make a
new person I don't want to make a new person wait hold on hold on hold on hold
on
this is the last seven in my hand no there's one more seven in the deck so
throw that away there's two sixes in the deck there's two nines in the deck how
many queens oh keep the queen holy crap I'm actually using real strats in real
time it's most likely I'm gonna roll a queen I'm gonna roll a queen
right I'm gonna play a high card on purpose because the queen I should roll
a frickin queen there's three queens in this deck
oh no I'm gonna go over I want to level up my pants I want to level up my pants
don't use it I don't have any discards left right I can't level up my pants so
just go for it I can't level up my pants girl okay next game next game we'll
level them up play the pear no it's not times it's plus so it's a lie planet
cards in your consumable area give a multiplier for their specific specified
progress planet card in your consumable area what does that mean that seems big
is it big I don't even know how to utilize it as yeah I've never seen you
before planet cards in your consumable area give like up here hold the Uranus
up there but I feel like I get so much more of Uranus oh wait just buy and stick
Mars up there and then buy that and then buy these and I can still level up
yeah yeah that's what the game is instructing me to do surely surely that's
what the game means for me to do brain is expanding so much your head will be as
big Uranus soon Brian anonymous thank you for the tip I'm getting good look you
have to admit come on anonymous I'm actually getting good like I'm actually
getting a five-head so I've just bought a thing and if I understand it correctly
wait how is there oh my god they're touching each other they're in love burn the
Mars car wait I'm to burn it if you have a Uranus card you bought and didn't use
it multiplies no what planet cards in your consumable area give for their
specified so I have to so where Mars is right now I have to put Uranus
ah the Mars will only help for the kind so the Mars only ah yeah you may as well
use it okay sorry I understand okay if I get an Uranus I'll buy it and not utilize
it because it will help with times multiplier not plus my multiplier well
any of you will remember do a BDSM test yes just go in their memberships and
you'll find a lot I'm pretty sure she be doing the tier list max doubles your
money max a 40 quid payout no I need to level up my pants which I've
successfully done plus 36 make it 38 and then what are you at if Joker Joker's
at 60 chips is what we're doing we're doing it we're doing it no you're
spanky oh turn car what do you get the planet what do you do no we stink no
they are all stinky okay planet cards let's go so keep it don't use it keep it
don't use it okay okay hold okay mommy's holding on mommy's smart enough to
hold on something right what are going on with you at 1.5 of this card stays in
the hand and it's a time we triggering this card one time four plus no we want
times what do you do your plus 10 but having a times 1.5 is stronger than a
plus 10 steel norders oh my god I'm actually learning okay wait is this the
last round Danny reroll and spend money wait was anyone paying attention what's
my rounds upcoming okay okay spend everything next match spend everything
next match okay let's go let's go let's go let's go let's go I don't know why I
looked at that I was gonna do any man right what pair shout out to all my
pairs okay we got a double we've got a level up let's go let's go let's go what
are you gonna hit 97 okay now we can spend like it's no one's business give
me that tarot card give me the fucking card glass or planet no right lucky
cards just shove them on doesn't really matter at the end of the day for you
celestial choose one of right okay so we can actually use this one oh my gosh
it's Uranus who to thunk but what are you at now level 20 400 times 21 that's an
even bigger number than the last time I calculated it I don't know that's like a
big number I don't know right reroll bye reroll bye use Mercury for your
Uranus oh it's a pair well I just buy and spend it on planets in case I'll get
like all messed up maybe I can reroll a Uranus okay we're gonna buy tarot oh no
sugar oh sure whatever it's the last round
I don't know what I mean mommy do you want to play endless if so keep a little
behind we lose an endless anyway I'm gonna try and see if I can win with
every deck this is yellow deck with one with blue so we're gonna try red deck
next
what do you do flips and shuffles all joke no that's not gonna hurt me too
much gee I wonder what this one is as if I wasn't staring at it for like half a
century right you you you and you get to talk
you you and you and you hover it doesn't mean I mean yeah see it's fine what
you worried about how are you feeling what you worried about oh I should have
used that silly me hold on let me use it what you you you read so all you get
hard get hard get hard okay oh no we don't have any doubles of anything okay
now I need to do it we've got four kings four aces four Queens and then the lower
half is like literally all been discarded so if I don't start getting
doubles after this the game's right yeah that's yeah that's what thought yeah
mm-hmm yeah yeah mm-hmm yeah mm-hmm that's right give me my win give me my
win 40 oh right let's try endless motor looks like you weren't fluffing no I
was trying hard in a GG I'm sure you'll get 1.1 came for him for 10k I think
that's my highest amount oh no best hand sorry 3 11 right let's try it endless
mode and see how far we get now I do know endless mode things get out of
control like so quickly and
spectral sure I know I spent all my economy we're not try hard and don't
worry we're not try hard and add a foil effect to a selected card convert all
cards into a single random one convert all cards in hand to a single random
suit sure we'll do we'll do you why not we're not gonna last long in unlimited
mode it just it just never runs with move the second Joker to the right yeah
why do you keep moving them you stinky game I had you guys like set up like
that don't think I don't remember how I had you say oh anyway I know exactly how
I say look okay we're gonna do that as well yeah why not
skip blame no there's no playing skip and we'll just play every round but what
do you do enhances to selected cards to a multi-card sure show views on you to
them multi-card and then look wow yeah
we've got an upgrade in our pair of pantyloons we're still one shot in oh my
god he's twitching he's ready oh oh okay let's do this and then you already
know what we're doing I don't even know how high this can go 21 yeah we can get
to 30 before the game ends I don't know that card is rubbing right I'm not
looking at the skips anymore I don't want okay I see nine
everything has well I don't know how that worked out but it did oh no I could
it in a full house and that would have no not two pairs way more effective
oh oh this is the big most insane run ever I'm sorry but hello oh my gosh I
think his urinus is keeping up with the things planet cards appear more
frequently I'm tempted I feel like because we're going all in on doubles
I'm sorry if that was the bad choice I feel like cuz we're going all in on
doubles all heart cards are debuff does not make a difference to me I sure you
may like it's just one insane
literally literally this is insanity
brah did I fart do you guys hear that it's under the does nothing odd I don't
have no money to buy it and we need to buy it a few times air in an extra dollar
of interest for every five you have at the end of the room
celestial park yeah oh my goodness it in the shut up again gee what does it even
say 460 by 24 what what what what oh wow we've jumped up holy crap we've jumped
yeah this is an insane jump that's an insane jump I have to admit that's that's
a bit much that's a bit much you should think about your actions okay that's a
bit much
I'm not gonna regret not throwing something away okay that's fine we
went what do you do well it stays in hand okay leveling up her pantyloons
again oh sugar that got big fast oh dear I want to keep that in my hand I want
to keep that in my hand as well shit I think it's over it gets so hard it gets
so hard so quickly unless how much did I just make I mean with those
duplicates on the map I will buy and use that now to level up a little guy
turret card absolutely give me that bad boy diamond steel double money I want to
double money so I can just go all in the steel is so big like if a steel is
lurking around that 1.5 and sorry I maybe have made the wrong choice there I'm
gonna redeem this cuz I need to redeem it 10 times someone said before I
actually unlock what it does I do apologize if I'm completely fucking
it up okay I'm trying my best and I'm at 56 plus small fire make it 58 buddy
were you actually currently a hundred chips yeah he is like gaining wow that
wasn't a lot oh he's twitching he's ready oh he's ready he's ready for
Freddy right there's two twos left so get rid of that there's only one four
left so get rid of that everything else is still pretty high probability where
is the king a king and a jack I can't believe I'm doing this but I'm actually
getting rid of them oh you fucking bastard I need odds people the three is a
high order rule in I want to hold on to the seven the eight right King is a low
roll eight is a low roll three is a high roll I'm gonna ask for a seven
what the fuck
hold on hold on mommy's doing math get rid of one five get rid of one six nine
I've only got two nine so you're not gonna show up a queen is more likely to
show up oh it worked out in the end it worked out in the end please get
twitching baby it's time get twitching get twitching oh oh oh oh oh oh we didn't
weep we didn't weep oh oh oh oh what's gonna do something silly but this is
gonna spawn in my planet card so I'm gonna use this because she is so kind
and spawns in my plan what I thought by default she spawns in my card no I thought
she spawned in my card by default okay okay it's fine it's fine it's fine okay
it's just the Celestia pack okay it's fine I'm sure I'll come across another
one I'll just buy that anyway cuz you know what do you do one now it's fine I
don't need that right all face cards are debuffed good thing I don't need to
rely on that eight seven six five four I mean I can randomly play a flush if I
wanted to just to get rid of all of these since oh that's rubbish though that's so
rubbish I think I'm better just getting rid of these sorry
uh-huh oh yeah all right get rid of you get rid of you is eight I'm no down an eight
ten has much of a chance to show up jacks have a high chance to show up a king I
don't want to I don't want to throw I don't want to do this but for the motherland
okay I worked out somehow I worked out I know it's debuffed but we'll see what
happens yeah I know it's debuffed but oh
Gimli I heard that shit oh my god I'm actually gonna have to avoid those
card shark activated though oh okay there's not much fours there's three
fives remain and there's only two sixes nine there's a very high chance of a
nine showing up queen can't these are the luck I need the king what's the jack the
lower percent okay there we go let's see what happens okay
is this the end is this the end of my endless oh I don't have any more
discards oh no this can't be I think this is it I think this is the end of our
endless mode you could use a high card as a discard I think I'm gonna have to I
want to hold on to you you all can go eight there's only two on the field five
there's three on the field four there's only one left no get in to get rid of
yeah king you can go you've done your service nine I want to keep because of
the multiplier so we're gonna play and get rid of you all don't disappoint me
am I reading that wrong or is the game trolling me with odds tough luck okay I
was gonna say I'm a I was like did I get that completely wrong and
misunderstand okay so this is the last four this is one six there's two more
nine there's two more 10 there's two more Jack there's such a high chance of a
five games trolling you what I would say yeah okay 10 has to go we want the nine
in hand Jack has to go your debuff
this is rubbish I'm not gonna make it no right if I use only one of them you
don't give me anything special other than we're gonna keep that name in the
hand we're gonna keep the ace in the hand in the hand yep and then just use
five well that was a good endless run oh wait he's twitching he's twitching no
he was twitching was he not was he getting close oh that was a fantastic
how close was that I wasn't even off that much that was so good we did it we
unlocked have a gold playing card with a gold seal when round begins add a random
playing card with a random seal to your hand Joker unlocked when a run without
playing three of a kind well you don't have to tell me twice
ghost deck unlocked when a run with yellow deck on any difficulty spectral
cards may appear in the shop with a hex card in one hand Erin at least one
million poker chip each played nine of spade gives time to Molly when scored
card changes every round okay so we have a little seal here to save we've done
the yellow deck we've done the blue deck so we're gonna actually do the red deck
which is the one you're supposed to start on but I never got it so we have an
extra discard round and rerolls the next no we don't care about next base
edition shop has a Joker only get that bad boy may get that bad boy right let's
see what we're looking with and let's see what we're cooking and looking with
right refresh your brain we can do a flush not quite royal but a flush
nonetheless reset oh wow bang on the flush gave us bang on the demand okay
right let's take it easy let's take it easy last times five I think we keep
our money I want to build a con oh no I'm skipping I'm skipping for the Joker
oh hey stencil you take it times five I trust you refling I trust you refling you
know what you're doing better than I do right we've got a double of a off the bat
okay now remember they don't score the way the way it usually scores we've got
a single pair they're gonna take us over the edge is there you go and just like
that just like that don't mind if I do it right what's her free oh brother this
guy stinks okay a permanent discard make coming handy put him in front of the
stencil yes sir she keeps skipping the straight I'll skip your straight in a
minute I don't I don't know what that means but right there's no point in
doing any of this stuff after defeating the boss get 25 all face cards are drawn
25 bucks economy right at the start it's honestly pretty good shop has a free
uncommon oh fuck it sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm feeling it I'm
feeling it I'm feeling myself right now shit I never thought that far ahead hold
on a minute I've I've I've severely didn't think that through and what do
you do first plate face card give a two plus multiplayer wins scored I'm going
to play all of this and then I'm gonna play five of the face down card oh well
that actually worked out really well somehow I don't know how but yeah that
went really well um I'm just gonna keep doing this okay and then we're gonna play all five
four of a cane yeah I was a bit overkill for that one I'm not gonna lie it worked look it worked
what defeat the boss blind wait oh 25 dollars I forgot already okay and you're free sell this
card to disable don't make me too disappointed now she okay does nothing we'll redeem it because
I don't know when this is gonna unlock uh right we're gonna need to start shaping our deck I would
like to shape it please
doubles all listed probabilities is that good I've not discovered it
scammed yeah honestly take the blank but yeah
doubles all listed probabilities I think run a flush deck this time okay let's try flush
all the same color flush it down the toilet that's how it works three of a cane
is that what we want
more just cards it's easier to find a suit okay all the same color
you're starting to get a bit me
it's free it's free
flush and three of a kind is very hard to work with flush five my beloved yes sir
any as long as you call me your little seaweed and then anything for you okay all the same
color heart heart heart heart so all you guys can go to Spain
am I being trolled heart you're not heart you're not heart you're not heart go away
go away
okay
yeah that's what I thought that's what I thought
yeah that's what I thought freaking getting trolled you can sort by suit okay I will remember that
uh don't need tariffs and stuff sorry I would I just want to save my economy I don't know
I want to get 50 economy I'm not I'm I don't feel very confident about our run I'm being honest
unless unless unless unless the tarot cards I can start swapping deck to like one deck color
shit you only get five interest right now anyway
I guess it's wheel of fortune who do I want to on though like
me
please the last tire or planet card use none so it's not gonna do anything
either stencil or bluish the hanged man destroy
fuck it the wheel fuck it I love a good gamble oh oh I'm gonna get rid of that if I'm in trouble
oh well I tried okay let's see what's going on here create two random tarot cards sure
what we got two planet doubles money sure don't mind if I do create up to two random
planet cards okay I'm going for a flush I tried doesn't mean I got it but I'll upgrade these just
in case I find myself in a rough spot when blind is selected destroy joker to the right and
permanently I double itself out I don't get that at first hand of round has only one card no
okay knife will get stronger both destroying jokers and will enhance stencil
so
they won't paramount enhance stencil
I'm gonna end up leaving stencil behind
and wait hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on let me think let me think let me think
if I actually sell these two no they have temples multi oh I can't do math
oh my head is spinning stencil needs sell yes that's what I'm thinking get rid of stencil
for better stuff that comes in okay we're getting rid of stencil I'm sorry I'm sorry if it's the wrong
choice but I want rid of stencil right if it's all the same color flush it down what we got
we've got three hearts and we've got three jacks
and the deck is equal as it can be
oh I need to commit to one color what do you want heart
think hard think hard me think hard are you joking I'm a dumber okay we got another heart
okay we got no heart
finally one two three four five go
okay that's good that's good we are ahead but we're gonna need to get some juicy upgrades
what do you do 10 multiplier if you click no uh face face cards give a
they are not making this one easy really crap
select two to convert the ray creates a random joker must have room what we do random joker
our emperor again
I don't know I like doing the wheel just for the hell of it if this flush could grab the wheel
that'd be great wheel move wrestler in front yes sorry sorry sell stencil fuck you bitch
that's right I'm good at listening
so stencil can't pick up the wheel okay so I want to sell locador
I'm leaving him to win because if he picks up the wheel again I'm gonna be pissed
okay no one got the wheel that's fine um
um
I honestly I'm needing something to help with these fluffy
nothing's kind of helping me have pick up smells sure
wow nothing's really helping me though we're not really getting shaped
I don't give a fuck oh wait shit I do
I'm sure I'll hit something fuck that was awful
fuck it ah right what color diamonds I've got three
okay did I just lose like so many diamonds in that pack am I going crazy
so there's hardly any diamonds in the pack that three are on the board that's why and I used to
oh you know what all these and then go for clubs clubs have a higher chance
and not clubs the other one no one two three four
right so I just need one more then oh my god I'm so sorry I'm just joking right it's hard
couldn't actually you know what we're never doing flush again because we
right about time go I swear this game loves trolling like it genuinely loves trolling
okay we got 12 that's good
played cards with suit gives a fucking three plus no one consumable slot
this is specific I'll show you my consumable slot I'll have you know adds double the rank
uh pick that up and go for spade flush spade flush okay
okay whatever we can say because I'm too dumb to figure out how the freaking flushes work
the only thing I'll be flushing is myself down the toilet because I remember what I'm playing
uh actually good hello actually good hello hello hello hello
hello actually good okay then what are you
all right as much as you want to find the arena packs and convert the space as much as possible
literally wow are you oh a tarot card when destroyed
I'm tempted
I'm tempted I think the tarot gamble use that and convert it to a spade
yeah I know exactly one consumable slot this thing up here
I mean do I need it not really
maybe if I accidentally redeem the um not the hyrule fan the one that gives to right spade
and a spade looks like this yeah goodbye everything
goodbye everything goodbye everything goodbye everything I want a spade card
spade and spade yeah goodbye okay one two three four five let's go
not bad but we are gonna need some planetarium upgrades because it's not
wait wait wait wait I had this splash card in another run is this not op is anything
is this not op is anything splash isn't great on flush though
oh no say it's not true hold on hold on say it's not true not good with a flush build
no how fucking how many times have you guys played this game how do you move so well
um right okay spade a face card a flush and then I can sell that when I panic
actually what's ahead of me playing cards played against with that air debuff that's fine
I I'm gonna be honest I don't think this is a winning run I've maxed out a deck in this game
and all difficult okay now far too much never played it I have like 60 plus hours that's decent
you gotta start putting face uh face cards yes that will be very nice
right my lovely spade you're not spade you're not spade you're spade you're not you're not you are
goodbye
can I just do that though
I know it's not a face card but I think it gives me enough
hold on let's test it how much does it give me
oh no oh no that's actually not good
sorry buy suit yes sorry I said I was gonna do that and then I'm not doing that okay so
I guess we're better going for clubs now
I said we're better going for cut loves now thank you
okay uh I will be admit I don't think I'm that confident
we have such high economy but we have nothing decent to spend it on right what are you
15 plus multi not times plus because there's a difference if you didn't know like don't
worry if you're new to the game don't be embarrassed if you're learning but you know some
some classic noobs don't know the difference between plus 15 and times multipliers there's
such goofy cubers you know right what are you a flat four multiplier you're just plus four you're
not times four though
I don't think we've won this run
so goofy I know it's okay you don't need to be embarrassed though like it happens
create a copy of a joker destroys all other jokers oh
oh
converse all cards in hand to a single random suit
there's too many clubs here to sacrifice into something else
gamble or do you want me to gamble it
fuck it
wait is that the right one was that the right one I didn't see it
oh my god it was the right one
wait it wasn't wait oh it wasn't it was club sorry they're both the same color so I can hardly see
the difference oh sorry I get confused between these symbols I feel like they're so similar
because they both have three points on them like do you know what I mean like point point point
flat point point point flat like they're the same thing I don't know if that sounds silly but
they're the same they're different but the same turn on high contrast mode you don't have to tell
me twice setting and before this is gonna be like so obvious now someone tears okay basically just
run in black suit flush now okay I mean I might as well just add a random freaking thing yeah
sure it's not gonna over discard it yeah
I'm needing I'm needing something better than what we've got I don't I do not believe I'm sorry I don't
believe I'm so oh it's blue abadi abadi right we have more blues than oh wait so yeah no already
I don't actually want to discard these too much though ah I don't like this run
I don't like this run at all
okay that was incredibly lucky because now we're gonna try and get spades one
which we are very close to getting a spade flush oh but I don't like this
discard creates a turret when discarded that's what I want that's what I want to see baby what
do you do two planet cards fuck it give me it yeah give me a street flush what do you do yeah
give me a flush that's actually what we needed okay one two three four five
why do you
fine then geez why is that so it's so pernicki it doesn't like me oh for gonna see great
creates a turret card when discarded well you're out what we looking at
there's actually quite a lot clubs right let's just
let's just throw everything into the wind what are you enhances multi-card
unbelievably we actually did it
and oh wow it removed their debuff as well how interesting
well that was considerable that Empress came in clutch I think we're gonna have to definitely
utilize turret cards a bit more re-rolls cost two bucks less well that's rubbish uh no that's rubbish
we are we are out here
we're doing what's called a flush not a straight a straight's when it's in a roll oh my god
a straight flush is the best we got like didn't even need Luke Kador I don't know
that interaction existed thanks for teaching me something what did it what did I do
you played them earlier that's why they're except okay
you need jipper or no straight flush is still technically a flush literally none of these options
right you I don't want you anymore you don't do anything what's the blind anyway
decrease of level played full for hand well sure sell you
oh one free re-roll I'll pop them on right now like I don't know
I don't like it I feel like we're like we're gonna lose and I'm putting on my
my time and effort and my love wait who has more
I have more clubs so I'll add another club and you come
did I re-roll for a better joker fuck earn five bucks for each discarded number three
these are shit
I don't know if I should buy that and just burn through
I feel like if we don't do something now we're in so much trouble
no no these are awful nothing is complimenting
okay if I have a high economy fuck it I'm sorry these are terrible I do not have faith I'm so sorry
I genuinely don't have faith right now I don't have faith this is too much oh as if I need one of
each yeah okay get right I'm sorry I'm sure I'm like completely messing this up but I don't have faith
I know I'm wanting to change the strategy but we're not gonna like be able to do that
uh I don't have faith I'm sorry I'm a non-believer we're not gonna it's not gonna happen this
friend there's no way we're like just not making it I think we're going for him I'm sorry
sell the bull and go for plus money
do you have a lot of faith card I have more than average yeah
oh wait no hardly I've got like only two but I'm doing I'm going for flushes
and clubs
it's not really maybe it smells sale sorry maybe sell smiley 13 faith cards
oh
why is this so hard
no I need a new joker
why are these so awful
ah I'm getting sun locked I do not believe sorry
where was my biggest hand uh clubs are you a club no are you a club yeah and you come
uh just give me this shit sorry I'm just spending we're not I I do not I doubt right don't want diamonds
spades I'm happy to turn something into a spade right you can all become spades
oh someone says wheel no no wheel we need we need to go all in and then I need levels up on
fucking flushes but the game is refusing to give me a fucking flush
I swear god if I go for this and his shit I'm gonna be raging I'm gonna be raging
oh my god
oh my god right get rid of all that
where are you hearts I don't need heart I'm in fucking trouble right these two surely will
give me a fucking blue club okay thank you okay play the first one I've completely missed
that oh right okay okay okay okay okay okay okay let me get up let me get up let them get up
I've only got five hearts left and seven diamonds I can't even
I need a blue okay literally literally by a ball here we will make this if I get
and what the sigma I need I need I need speed
okay that's all you had to do that's all you had to do I think I believe
wow please let me level up flush this is awful
re-triggered re-triggers all cards played for the next 10 hands
man I can't take this shit no more we're freaking
due to your selling the dude early the boss's auntie still applies
no flush and only log you just unlabeled flush I mean it's free
this is the worst I think we've ever had flush finally took you long enough to show up don't
be shy to show up again I'm gonna need a permanent hand if we want to even have a slim chance of
winning right who is my most I've got clubs give me more club and club club money or club
sitting in the hand if it sits in the hand it's a lot more valuable
we're just splashed it's splash it's splash terrible pick up the voucher it's basically
a lifeline yes I actually agree uh do we want oh my god sorry if I go bug bite on my leg
refling what if you just bit me
reflames did one of you just bite me on my juicy thighs what's going on
all right okay splash does nothing sorry splash is good if your hand doesn't have less than five
cards okay it was me no I thought I literally just thought bug bite that's probably the only
scary thing no fuck off I don't believe it's gonna be any good Ardua
oh my god I think I'm gonna have to double skip
I need I'm like struggling to win but if I can have three hands in a round without having to discard
oh fuck it fuck it we're we're hardly gonna win so let's just go bigger go home
um
gee willikers I wonder what that card is hmm it's a mystery well good luck I sure hope I don't mess
this one up okay I love sorting by suit okay
okay
there's so little hearts in the deck you guys are not worth having around
diamonds again you're rare but we're only one off oh I wonder what that one is
chucks the game almost got me I don't think I'm gonna make it maybe
right if I hold you in my hand I'll hold you
oh wow I actually did it holy crap that paid off I don't know how about I did
okay right what is my joker
wait hold on copies the joker ability to the right hold on hold on hold on hold on
right you're about to perish anyway
what do you do speed okay yeah blueprint but with what
I think blueprint and then joker and then get rid of photograph
and that's gonna expire naturally which is fine
so get rid of joker because he only does it once
first played face card gives the times two multi win scoring I get that it's big but
yeah just get rid of photograph okay sell you copies the ability the joker to the right so buy
you put you here and then sell spritz because it's gonna expire anyway I understand I just get rid
of straight joker um what crafty joker you want rid of him it is only 80 chips if it's a flush
yeah no I'm um what do I need to sacrifice I feel like that's gonna expire so there's no
point in keeping it around
mmm the 80 chips
I feel like you're doing nothing bro I do right so copies the ability to the right and it's compatible
so it's giving me 15 multi plus 10 multi for an extra 25 multi flush isn't worth it yeah
have blueprint next to seltzer for now okay I will agree with that and then when it perishes
we will move it in front of him rip chips stop have a mess up please give me joker oh my god this
game hates me
none of these are useful for me right now unfortunately well I'll go with planet earth
because why not right we're gonna do playing card because I want to keep adding to my clubs
basically
yes please get in that it so we're 22 clubs 18 space only 10 hearts and 10 diamonds
definitely want to start getting tarot cards that override these hearts and diamonds would be best
honestly
what do you do no fuck off you rubbish offer
whoa okay you you you you you go
that was a lot of movement for me not comprehending create a tarot card when discarded
okay so diamonds and hearts you're out because you guys I don't have enough of you what do you do
enhances something into a steel card I mean sure just sit right there I doesn't really matter
like I can still get a value out of it than I
oh wait I put it should have put it on a lower one sorry sorry sorry it's fine it's fine it's fine
okay okay okay okay okay maybe we've recovered a little bit if we can get a few jippers to get
more stupor uh
I know I should try and keep economy I know
I know right please jipper is all I ask thank god and it is a flush all the same color
it's all the same color flush it down the toilet okay and then we're gonna add
uh another club from this pack that we're a hundred percent gonna get
oh no I mean the odds of a the tarot card is so valuable though I know that gives 50 chips
hmm what do you say
DNA can help you make some face cut boil is a good one because you want to play the clubs I know
the tarot card might just save my arse cheeks you're right
can I see if I wait oh right okay now uh if first hand on round only has one card
our dependent copy to deck and draw it that's a joker
another time another time we'll come back to you we'll come back to you another time right you
enhance two cards into a lucky card I mean I can do that for literally anyone sorry I keep
forgetting it's clubs blue okay so we can get rid of these because we can't have them
okay that was lucky ish
I definitely want to eliminate any hearts and diamonds at this point
if I can get a tarot card to bless us spritzer little spritzers getting a bit weak now
right one two three four five what do you do
I'll keep you for now I'll see if my lucky cards pop off
okay could be worse
create a tarot card when discarded okay against my best interest what do you do
say
okay whatever whatever right we're gonna have to do these unfortunately
I'll pop that in the oh wait I can't pop wait can I pop it in the shop I think I can't pop it
oh I'm getting nervous when we spritzer goes away though because it's ogre
no I'm need I'm needing jupiter's like I'm needing jupiter's bad that's what's gonna resurrect this
you can use it in shop okay that's good doubling money doubling money but actually this time not
scamming yay right what's going on here not you not you your ship I ask I pray I ask for jupiter
to get more stupider
I am being troll and that's okay jupiter I call upon you
no thank goodness gravy I am desperate I am on my hands and knees jupiter what are we looking at
not full house flush
oh we're literally have more in full house I can do it again right sure straight three of a cane
straight flush is the best I got next round I don't have the economy to be messing around how many
oh no he's about to break
full house is giving more than flush honestly because it's cheeky bad pause
yes it's just worth more
lose a dollar per car plate that's fine our economy's bad anyway does it mean oh we're
gonna keep that in hand hopefully one two three four five go
I took five bucks from me am I gonna go in debt I thought this was a fantasy game why is
they putting realistic aspects into gamble give me my money back what are you doing
give me that shit back great let's get rid of these give me my money back
what the heck is realistic okay now move blueprint to the left
so blueprint abstract and then if I play a face card and if I play a spade it's just
can we play cards when we run out of money I don't know I'm going to discard the tarot
because I want to see if it gives me a tree I gave me a tree literally taxes
literally got tax playing a freaking a gamble game thank you boy for the tip literally what the
heck right I want to keep that ace I want to keep the ace very badly because it's giving me a
multiplier here we go right 10 10 9 7 5 go have fun do something
I don't like that no the chances of me rolling another club is high I'm sorry I'm going to
have to sacrifice the ace I'm sorry I have to sacrifice the ace I didn't want to
no we lost we actually lost for realsies though the fuck do you do
no we actually I knew it I knew it freaking
as I have clubs clubs I need clubs
oh my god
not good not good
no wow that was so rough that was like a terrible don't play the scene
whatever you do don't play the scene you know what they say the house always wins
yeah you were freaking making sure I was losing that was terrible honestly
create a tarot card when blame just like this okay
I see you little card oh I was actually minus money as well that's quite funny
just so you know strong either it's a joker you unlock after you get three wild cards in your
deck that make your hearts and diamonds count as one suit the same for cotton space oh okay
right is there any easier deck at the end um these all look really hard okay sorry these
all look too hard let's just keep doing one extra discard we just need a joker to be kind to us okay
I'm here for it that's useless um right okay I can see a bit better now because of the different
clothes okay everything we remember throw out the window because
uh because I said so smile would I need a king a king and then we have a flush
fine doubles then jeez I just want to get the joker that's in the shop waiting for me
oh and there's the king yeah yeah yeah up my arse what does it say yeah um
I don't have a particularly high chance of rolling a flush
but might as well might as well go for it
I see this game see this game how dare this game make me so addicted to it but absolutely
clueless on what to do honestly right I can't believe I'm actually doing maths in a freaking
video game right just get rid of the lower number sorry I'm not counting fuck that how dare this game
make me actually use my brain honestly it has nothing but the cheek and the audacity to make
me use my brain all right we've got a full house surely full house will do it oh god
okay thank goodness right what's my real joker uh right
uncommon jokers give a multiplier right you know what's crazy I don't have any
right do we spend right we're only going to get one dollar interest anyway so we might as well go
for it uncommon uncommon and they're both common why because why wouldn't they be I'm losing it when
blind is selected to create two common jokers 12 three of a kind okay are we already shaping our
decks any deck shapers I'm shaping mine right now three of a kind three of a kind you'll never
guess what I got and a full house let's go three of a kind give me a baby
fuck you give me the rest right now we need to upgrade three of a kind we already have our shape
which is good okay and we've got clearance sale to lower the price of everything
oh if I do that I can only buy one pack
if mmm because you got free jokers you could just sell them I don't
if I get more rare that 1.5 gets out of control pretty quickly right what's the deal
okay this stays so if I keep my economy
I will get two dollars interest and then I'll buy it next round I'll keep my economy
oh you skipped the first yeah spectral is worth it usually
I only get one dollar interest if I go for it though I might as well just
fuck it go for it spend all create a random rare joker but sets money to zero you'll never
guess how much money I have on hand right now destroy one random card in your hand but add
three random enhanced face cards destroy one random and add four random enhanced number cards
wait incantation is better than familiar create a copy of a random joker but destroys all other jokers
go all in on three of a kind sell this and go all in on three of a kind
someone says take race it's not worth it okay race race okay
ah don't like obelisk although it's a very satisfying word obelisk wait are you going
on common you're a rare so do you count no it has to be an uncommon of course it has to be an
uncommon oh negative joker spot it let's go after defeating the boss gain 25
bucks I we kind of need economy so I'm going all in
oh don't mind if I do what what hello
it's over I just threw I just threw because of my lack of reading
I just threw because of my lack of reading why game why would you why why this psychic
this psychic why why now we have to roll for a queen we have to roll for a
are you joking me you have to play five cards social distancing please you have to play five
cards you know what you have to play up my arse honestly right five cards and a ten sure wait
they have more tens hold on hold on tens no I don't want to play you seven I want to play you
because there's not enough for you fucking up my arse all right that's right get right
that's right yeah that's right yeah that's right yeah give me that money hand over hand over sweet
cheeks uh play no not again please no more suits I can't handle them it gives me an extra
joker slot earned five bucks for every discarded number six but it'll change the number every
time right we're going all in on three of a kind any three of a kind honestly all these jokers are
arse you do not have to tell me that because I can they're literally terrible anyway three of a kind
what is three of a kind look like oh venice we want venice for three of a kind three of a
kind just making sure I want venice I have to make sure okay oh a speed suit I don't like
anything else that's on for sale here so I'm just gonna go next yeah you want venice we're like
vince us rerolls the boat card strong face down after each hand has played yeah fuck the fish
not physically
the water I don't think I've ever gone against the water before
uh I need to spend some money in the shop are you joking the water
my god
I need to go all in on like threes oh I missed
um
give me a three give me a three give me a three yes baby and then what a full house
just the three one three oh wait I could just throw it away well that worked out really well
in the end uh who or what uh eight you are not needed ace you're not needed thank you though
fantastic uh teamwork teamwork it's all it's all about the teamwork water is worse because
zero discards I'm in so much trouble for this next game lucky cards played aces give a little bit
of help right we're gonna buy this and you're gonna give me venice oh my god you're such a good
little thing you three of a kind okay we're going all in on three of a kind I can do this
okay two tarot cards are made okay that's fine what's the dealio wild card uh planets
might be worth the risk uh double in money maybe glass card or multi-card
you need the scholar holy hell is that a good joke
okay wait is the scholar there by the scholar okay okay okay uh priestess into empress okay
let's do planets I got venice I can't believe it actually got venice I'm so lucky right and then
last but not least uh into empress multi-card I don't know maybe if I get high economy I can
just spend absolutely everything fuck it sorry if I get high economy I can just spend spend
right you guys want me to get this scholar uh we'll just do this as well we'll utilize this
shortly we're not going to do this because it's going to lower my hand however I do have high
economy now so uh we'll just try your best um
um
high card
high card is all we can do right now
um
go for aces and 10 oh shit I've just used one
high card again
surely I'll get one triple okay that's all I needed we're going to double it up and we're
going to go quads and then we'll keep the fours we'll get rid of the two and the seven
and that's the best we can do right now
wow that was kind of lucky not gonna lie I was that was that was rough that was rough
we can double double's money wait am I getting an extra like fucking 20 quid for spending two quids
stop this is so good okay oh my god there's our two pair oh blank
we're almost gonna unlock whatever that is right tarot cards give me something I want baby
stone two more tarot cards sure give me two more
fuck wait do we want clubs no it's spades we won
one
were you
create the planet card for final play to poker hand in the round
create the tarot card planet create the planet card for final play
uh obelisk just saved you wait did that actually I was even paying attention
obelisk is dying is it I'm so sorry obelisk I'm not even paying attention to you I don't
like it because I can't like comprehend it strength is nice if you use it on 10
that's a brutal five of spades literally get money or a 50 foil as well
that wait that thing's stacked it's got the circle on it the gold and a seal
when I saw the bellel voucher I read that it's something totally different what balanese
if you have a blue seal at the end it's a free planet creates a planet card for final play
sell the first joker and obelisk what for it wouldn't aid me would it
want bat and just roll for a new joker
yeah yeah yeah okay wait if I just start I don't want to tire it I want to plan it
okay obelisk I agree with selling she still has a joker slot oh have multiple
you know what fuck you I literally don't have one uncommon
I'm going out on three of a cane
the two pairs can re-roll buy that and then re-roll
this joker gains two plus multiplier for every real roll in the shop well good thing I have
freaking economy are you joking is that a joke is that real
go for full house yeah
that's bizarre and it's uncommon right so you finally compliment you you mean bam
and then what you two are like card and then what are you just a random thing and you're random as well
you need to be at the end though so it's like active and then you
sell two pairs and buy a new joker
sell two pair and buy a new joker and now sell the first joker
Gigi should be at the end
why sell two pair yeah because my triple will get counted in a two pair if I do full house angle as well
fill house will trigger both of those yes that I re-roll to get a multi activity
I mean one re-roll can't hurt yeah he literally got it well
four of a cane no hi hi no
um yeah this is another rough looking one I'm gonna be honest
oh wait did I just fuck up did I just fuck up
I hope I didn't mess up no okay right so you're gonna activate when a double goes
you are gonna help you
I see aces so get rid of all of this oh I'm so close to a flush
honestly four of a kind apart you have to sell some jokers in New York yeah
right two pair three of a kind so I need a right I need to fill house
how am I so proud of this girl can I get a king or an ace please
I'm just gonna have to play something
two pair go for it and the ace should trigger on that at least
what do you do oh piss it's always too late increases the rank of up to two cards by one
right so I'm gonna make some nine some tens I know I suck you don't have to tell me
it's silly compare up to three selective cards to clubs sure let's make everything clubs
like it makes a difference to this point I can do a flush if I want to
uh just do two pairs again for how strong are you better than giving to me I'm getting
rolled and is this deck is like so hard for no reason hold on I want a double
there's more three four and six and eight can go three four six and eight can go and then I can get
I know for a fact I'm reading these odds correctly and being trolled out the wazoo
I know I am reading these correctly and can get a full house I am being trolled so hard
with odds right now holy holy holy holy holy holy right eight can get to fuck
six can get to fuck
I can I'm getting trolled so bad looking at the odds honestly
well where are you when your room begins add a random playing card with a random
feel to your hand well that's kind of cool four of a kind I don't really have that choose a joker
well it's gonna have to be better than anything I've got on my persons
every played card counts in scoring
gain 15 chips if it's a straight times four multi if played hand contains four of a kind
that's so rare I don't have any played it it's an uncommon the rare you want splash
is splash good with my current thing baseball jokers like having a laugh at me just sell them
no wait splash is bad oh the one in the shop is uncommon my apologies okay just skip these
I don't think I'm going to get rid of what eight chips or 12 plus
what one sell the two of a kind pair two of a kind okay I'll take your advice
and you come right so now you are giving me multiplier for that as well when round begins
add a random playing card with a random seal in your hand or or a seal in in your hand more likely
than you think okay add a playing card make it good make it a tarot or something oh right
we roll so I can boost him boom right what do you do a joker a tarot a planet and a
spectral card may appear multiple times what does that mean this joker gains three plus
chips paired discarded club card new card with a seal
two parts is in the Fibonacci sequence he's better than scholar is he I mean I'll take
him he's uncommon so he's gonna hit with him fuck you scholar and you come you
we now have 1.5345 and then six times six multiplier because of all these guys
surely that's how it works surely I'm gonna re-roll again to give him a little boost
I know I shouldn't but each played queen of diamond gives a two times malt that's a bit much
I mean you could get like multiple of the baseball jokers yeah I feel like a bit of that
that was like a dog and not a seal or or wait moose
am I good pup for you so many uncommon literally that's uncommon as well
that one's far too specific though yeah what do you mean my seal sound isn't good or
or you know you you buy upgrade high card by three levels well I'm not playing high far
first hand is drawn face down that's fine well why did you shake when discarded
I've got three discarded not discard me I don't really want to discard these either
you're always good to stand straight right discard for attire
the lovers into a wild card oh my god it's so wild why is the card wild we'll never know
I want to keep that 10 because of that the thing
uh what the fuck am I supposed to play three of a kind
okay
three of a kind speed and then holy shit that's it that's all I can do
I mean it did something something was popping off I don't I don't exactly know what but it was
pop a lock and choose playing cards or choose playing cards
cool house I live for the wild I do love a dapper moustache
noodles yes you are a good little seaweed I love that fucking nickname
let's just get a little seaweed tell you I'm a little seaweed I'll be flowing in the water
sell the first joker and reroll for an uncommon really
fuck it give me an uncommon shit
I would have to completely change up my plan I think it's too late to change a strategy like that
is it too late for fancy pants
it's trusors nope it's worth it trusors works with a full house
right uncommon uncommon uncommon and I can't get rid of that guy because he lets me hold
the or everyone um
put the pants first sorry I always forget that part
uh 7.5 on uncommon isn't bad maybe if we can swap to the two pair angle it's not too bad I
I'm gonna buy
right what are we looking at
chance to win money though
chance to win money or double the point I feel like money because when we reroll
this little guy's getting stronger every time we're gonna next round it first hand is drawn
face down that's fine uh unless that one isn't so we know by rank that we've got pretty low batch
of cards I have four attempts to get 10k
hmm don't buy so many cards a slung deck is more reliable
wait no fuck it hey we got a double in there
okay oh that was such a waste I'm sorry
I've done it now
okay I have a lot of 10s I don't have a lot of 9s 8s I'm waiting on showing up 3 and 2 you
can fuck off while you're at it right what are you bonus cards right that's what I want
7 and 3 you can both perish 10 uh 8th and jack I mean I don't want you to perish but
we're getting desperate here oh come on oh sorry my stomach's rumbling I'm hungry
I need a 10 or an 8 oh wait no what am I doing I have fucking fancy pants oh for fuck's sake
you dumb yeah you dumb person I have fancy pants now okay sorry I need to mentally change up the
strats I have fancy pants I need to do him oh I'm so sorry
I don't need triples I need doubles we're going back on the doubles wow I have one discard
uh ace I've got rid of too many you too I've got rid of many
five I'm very likely to show up nine and ten
and queen all equally oh fuck this is a terrible truck oh I paid off though
wait no I didn't yes I did I tell the lie go doubles go multiply do your thing
wow right must remember fancy pants I have fancy pants now
are you guys okay if I go get a snack after we lose this one I need a wee snack
full house was also an option was it okay no was it full house oh yeah yeah yeah
full house would activate two pair anyway okay another uncapped well we can't really
change up anything uh sell this card to create a free double card I don't know what that is
uh no I need the rounds when blind is like no
turret card oh please oh please what's two pair I've forgotten
oh Uranus in you come we're doing two pair strategy we might be able to do it in time
to save the run to swap now would I need delete spades that I don't think anything happens spades
maybe turn turn stuff into spades fuck it turn stuff into spades sure everything comes spades
we're gonna reroll to increase our little buddy there add one stone to deck when blind is selected
one and two chance to create a turret card when any booster pack is open
wow that seems pretty OP but I would lose out on something
yeah I would lose out on a multiplier it's good at the start it's too late now okay agreed agreed
um I'm gonna reroll no I'm not I'm gonna go next shit okay what are you initial cards and
booster packs are free in the next shot ah do we want it no we need to level up pants we need
to level up pants don't don't get distracted don't let this the the game distract me with its
it's fiendish uh things creates a planet card for final played poker hand of round of held in hand
okay I'll try and hold on to you then okay I've got my pants let's level up my pants please
let's get your level up okay who are we looking at I'm gonna keep my five I want my five in my hand
uh everyone else can kind of just reroll
I've got one right three your your odds are down seven your odds are down dramatically
eight do I want eight eight your odds are up ten your odds are not as high as eight
if we're doing it purely on odds
oh wait no ah fuck it
yeah okay that worked out let's go yay I think I did it and we're leveling them up that's
perfect okay okay whoa no yes yes flash mark no maybe hang on sometimes
uh straight flush no yes yes okay I understand nothing about the game but here in mummy thank
you so go in do you like here in the cogs turn big yes okay big yes um
uh create a turret card when blind is selected no do boosters
give me what I want to see which is two of a king three of a king high card four of a king
I doubt I'm going to achieve that like yes we'll just shove on dinner
have you seen this seen this seen this seen this venus venus venus but not to be confused with
what is showman even do uh he can make something repeat itself I don't know what the odds are but
and then we'll use a turret okay spades is coming in again wow you're a spade already
spade spade and spade right you're all becoming spades right now whoa a la kazam okay and then
we're going to reroll
showman allows multiple or repeat two players to show up oh right I don't really I can delete two
cars I really want that
um maybe I don't know about that
why does it look so evil delete some non space delete some low non space okay I actually just
okay another time I guess I will do one more reroll to let this little guy get up a bit more
boom whoo this joker gains a monthly every time a planet is used currently at one time
and it's an uncommon hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
hmm he can get leveled up and he's an uncommon
swap showman
maybe yeah okay and you come
right as we use planets we will get a bit stronger thank you showman for your help
we do appreciate it um I am gonna fart so I'm gonna mute I'm not even kidding
oh I'm silent but was it deadly we'll never know okay I get money for playing this okay
we're gonna level up fancy pants and we're gonna delete very small theme let's go
let me see let me see well again okay we got 12k that's fantastic
we do have a double of a
I want to destroy a lower three wait why do I have so many twos
two two two two what right I'll try and delete two we space that's a lot of we space
I bet it smells like popcorn oh do you guys smell that smells like popcorn
take a big walk right where do I do create the planet card if it's held
wait no geez that almost oh I don't really want to use it but if it means I can level up my things
then keep the space this isn't actually a very good discard range
you need to keep and not use the other five delete the other lows
well delete that one
because it levels up urinus and your joker this
yeah that five is too important to use okay I'll throw away the five
that worked out holy moly thank you well we want cake surely that's what your username is
yeah yeah it's we want cake thank you we want cake for becoming a member I appreciate it wait
you want my cake right now you want me a clap for you right now wait a minute did you find my
channel from that short that I just released be honest be honest did you just find my channel
because of the short I released about me clapping here it in it oh who are the odds
what are the odds a reliable username yes okay played face cards have a one in
nah nah right we are gonna very kindly ask um panda riots why are the pandas rioting
we don't know wow we're actually getting kind of i'm gonna say why are the pandas rioting
and just thank you for becoming a member of she is strunny hold on show urine had to
tackle a bunch of them stuff how are you feeling about this one um it's we've had to swap to doing
doubles again this is so OP but because we're having to swap we're kind of doing the we're doing
the u-turn at the moment we're not quite crashed into the tree just yet but we're getting okay hold
on no fuck that we're going for money and then i'm going to do re-rolls to boost my little guy here
re-roll
re-roll boost my little guy why not
urinus you're just who i was looking for you silly belly
no uh re-roll uh let's do lucky cards sure uh one more re-roll to boost my guy urinus
oh right fuck you urinus go fuck yeah urinus right okay we're good to go let's go next
we've got a little boost here no repeat
repeat
melda i better make it can then um
no
um
i sold it did i sell it
did i just sell it oh no oh i'm so sorry i was oh right that's when you know i need food in my
system i can't believe i sold my butt for money what i sold my butt for money what these these
accusations hold the seven for a full house wait for real for real yeah i'm going to destroy that
so i can get a turret card um destroy the nine all the ten i know it has a chance but a chance
is a chance a chance isn't fake oh fuck off that's terrible
preposterous the five-minute brew fresh peaches come get your fresh peaches wait so you want me to do what
what do we want to do a royal flush sorry a full house i know i'm using this and i know i shouldn't
but we can't repeat the same hand
a full house i think is what we're also going to use that what do you do if held
it doesn't really i'm just gonna use it doesn't really matter right i know i shouldn't uh maybe
for the first one we'll do we'll do right okay okay we'll do doubles for the first move
and then we'll do a full house for the next one surely
oh right do not sell do not sell do not miss click here is a miss input here is a miss input
come the fuck down okay okay that worked uh not you can i get urina because i made a mistake
no okay uh full house will you do you
uh you got or no 1.5 okay we're getting there we're getting there that's 1.5 wait is that 1.5
no he bounces off himself he doesn't bounce on anyone else's
yeah um impress like to do multiply and then we'll do a re-roll
wow what are you guys i've never seen create a tarot card if hand is played with four bucks
or less no that per plan he doesn't lose anything right i've got plus 24 in the molly on the shop
fan each played card with a heart nah i knew he didn't sing for me all right i'll do one more
re-roll to level up my little guy we are at 24 and we're at 26 yeah these are rubbish rubbish
rubbish next round let's go
no you do not wait no no i will double up my pairs okay i'm a good girl hold on i'm gonna see
for some reason
no that definitely did not work for some reason youtube memberships do not show up on the activity
feed and um what's the application called the obs window type thing instant two pair wait
where hold on i wasn't paying attention sorry right hold on uh right played
aw if i hold it though what do you do you just make stuff enhances two molly cards
i see a full house do i just go for it
that'll still level up a two pair this stroke again molly if the played hand contains a
two pair okay wait hold on maybe if we can get a seven i'm just gonna do one discard don't worry
it's not a big deal ah fuck it we'll do the whole thing
yes i commit i commit
i know i should have done the planet for the bonus or whatever i know i know but let me be dumb
oh let me be transparent even at iron five oh my god i really need to eat food holy crap my
ability to read is like crashing right now wow choose a tarot card okay we'll do tarot
what we got here a tarot um uh earn 14 bucks oh planet cards right you can piss oh no
okay it's fine we got urinus it's fine it was worth worth hashtag worth
and we're leveling up this little guy i'm so sorry i freaking it's so annoying because i'll
click it and then my brain instantly goes you stupid bitch and then i'm like and then i'm like
imagine how frustrating it is for you watching right now being like oh my god she is doing this
live at the exact same time as i breathe and tape and she is still making the exact same mistakes
from the very first time that she plays it like honestly right okay these are rubbish rubbish
we have enough for a reroll to boost our little baby and again we will boost our little baby one
more time uh and then we're good to go three molly if you have at least 16 attacks no oh wait
no no no no you completely outdo any of that he completely outdoes any of that that is pretty
good but he does the work
um i mean plenty of dumb plays but i'm not even streaming this is the baltro experience okay that
makes me feel better then when i reach out and someone says three times molly is massive and
i've already clicked off of the shop and i can't get access to the card again uh
okay we pretend we did not see that card it does not exist okay we're gonna level up our double
base uh yeah straight up level up two hands
the game loves me just admit it you want to make out with me game
stop it i'm blushing right so uh every i get a multiplier and it's literally only two bucks
and i know it doesn't really help what i'm doing but this multiplier is gonna add up real quick
don't don't jinx the streamer look oh but i kind of wonder
do you remember to eat my sweet mirror right now
brian remember to eat and hydrate the aguva colon none of us call love
oh i'll let i'll i'll love your colon anytime thanks for the tip narrow i will eat after we
lose this one i promise one more we're playing one more after this one more wink wink wink nudge
nudge only one more um
um don't want to mess around with tarot cards yes i do i do and i don't want to pretend otherwise
hermit gives me 20 bucks back honestly
give me my money back give me a refund right now right reroll
rubbish reroll rubbish reroll
yes
rubbish you should be embarrassed right give me that then give me this give me my money back
what hermit wild card
compared to no steal
okay okay i'm satisfied next round let's go
discard two random cards every time you play a
we are gonna go full house if that's the case
what do you do
well let's just use the el diablo
uh right one two three four five because it's going to throw away something at random
i'm just going for it the lover's card
yeah that looks about right that i threw away our doubles of either end
oh we won wait i believe i believe i unironically believe hold on
i'm only gonna buy this because again it levels up our spectral joker
i believe wait we are like wrecking and decking hold on three of a kind straight flush or straight
three of a kindle yeah yeah three of a kind sure yeah even though it's supposed to be doubles
give me hermit right now give me my money back okay no close enough three of a kind
i mean this is more valuable because it levels up this guy
and then we'll reroll as an as the number of times poker hands has been played to this
run to the multiplier the multiplier sorry that's really getting stuck i actually starting to believe
what's the boss blind uh one in seven cards get faced down
that's that's easy peasy lemon squeezy easy peasy lemon squeezy uh no trouble okay reroll
i'm just gonna do it for this little guy here because his multipliers it we're literally getting
close to that three times which we skipped on and he gives us a 1.5 on top of him
i believe i believe call me justin beaver because i believe
this i'm sorry that was shut up i'm getting delirious i need to eat um
i could go for a full house
okay that's fine full house full house let's go level up our fancy pants again over here
and we got freaking planets a reward yeah thank you news please
uh social distancing please uh splash in history i think at this point it's too late bro it's too
late even though it is a foil um it's too late two piers better than a uh a full house at the
moment due to due to my butt wouldn't my butt ever do to you uh this is just no oh sure
wait i'm gonna get a flash no oh it doesn't really matter it doesn't i'm not using any of them
whatever whatever major loser
i'll buy her to use her
okay okay okay i believe right you guys said duple vase what do you do i'll have to discard it
whatever what whatever wait hold on no imagine if that was a three and i could have bumped it up to
well bump up the queen
okay
hold on if i got any special kings i've got five kings i've got four i've only got three jack
king queen strength okay okay okay okay right that way we can discard you and get a tarot card
as a reward and discard that four while we're at it and the two that's we don't want it really
but did i get just that i don't want to destroy any cards
let's see if we can do it
wow oh i believe i believe sorry i believe i'm a believer i couldn't leave her if i attract call
me donkey from shrek because i'm off on one i'm just buying that for the he's 2.8 come on
score some two pairs two pairs two pairs in a pod two pairs in a pod
i've got enough on call me use the tarot card immediately give me my money back and give me the
hermit back okay multi increase rank spades clubs uranus uranus get in my belly get in my belly
in the in the wise words of that one movie i've still yet to see but it has uh is it michael
mackin no not michael mackin tire uh fucking mike mires uh and he's like getting my belly
uh reroll for the boostio on my oh okay sorry sorry these are gonna boost my this guy he's
a bit well he's three point freaking two oh feels good man have you seen brave i have seen brave
wow
ah
i mean i might oh i could have got two planets out of that one
draft i could have got two planets out of that one
um
it would be very nice if i could get a queen or a jack right now
wait is that there anything no i needed a queen or a jack oh but we can get one planet
oh when discarded
what the fuck am i trying to achieve what are you trying to do wake up
what are you trying to achieve i don't know you're scaring me
well you want any oh my god i'm addictive what who are you if first discard of brown
has only one card destroy it and earn three but i've never seen you before welcome welcome you renaf
glass is worth it i'm scared of glass i don't want to break any cards right you tarot card
give me hermit right now or fool close enough uh clubs no change a card
no increase rank um a steel card molly player
blue seals give you a planet that corresponds to the winning hand so urinus is guaranteed if i win
oh real true increase the rank no
convert the left into the right what if i did something crazy like astronomically crazy
and put an eight shit there's no eight sorry let me try that again and put a 10 there's no 10
okay let's try again and put a two next to the seven and then the seven will create a planet seal
and then that means there's two planetarium chances which means i can further upgrade my
planetarium card as well as urinus death slight delay the left turns into the right damn right
i'm so smart oh my god i'm actually sometimes you know what sometimes sometimes yeah you know what
um uh right let's reroll just to get him up he's at 46 now he is feeling himself no
maybe if i get another negative can i get seven can i get seven joker cards if it's a negative
yes okay okay we're gonna skip it we're gonna skip we're gonna shuffle down we're gonna get a
little skipy um we're not gonna do the free because we already have a guaranteed oh my god look at all
the planets we could have uh kings and sevens because these are gonna act as what i need oh well
maybe that seven actually yeah sure
i believe i believe in the spare trousers i believe in the spare trousers i believe in the spare
trousers i will i will go off road and in my jeep for the spare trousers i don't have a jeep i have
a bike um you'll never catch me driving i ain't going oh i believe oh we're gonna win
oh no
i believe we're gonna do it oh my god level 16
based bacon joyer yes i got booby okay what do you do re-trigger each played number card
yeah that's fine and it's uncommon oh so he works well with a baseball oh my god
right one reroll to boost my little guy here oh cheeky reroll nothing of interest
flip and shuffles all joker cards uh good thing it actually doesn't matter for the most part
maybe a little bit okay okay let's look at let's look at the hand i see
i see snow paws um sorry that was such an easy joke to make i mean we could just get rid of the
thing discard discard discard i'm sorry it was such an easy joke to make four i've got four four
seven seven seven five seven is it okay i went on first try so that i destroy this and
no fuck it use that it's better to have a planet boost than anything else
oh wow yeah
yeah we unlocked a new deck oh it looks like i've taught you well
wait but let me use urinus i want to keep going you can't stop the fun no
okay what are you a ball of ramen two teams multiplayer loses uh for each card discarded
over time yeah card give me my money back no a wild card um and then a lock sure let's just
shove you on the lock why not oh two okay addicted to urina mommy wants the more your
friend literally why do you keep giving am i going crazy or is this not going away i keep getting
go away please
okay we're doubling her up we're gonna we actually i want planetarium
yeah i want planetarium
new joker i could really play one hunting
it better be doubles or i've literally lost this endless already right if i discard no
this game knows what it's doing to me
if i discard i get tarot but i don't really need a tarot i need planetariums more than anything
so i'll go for it i'm leveling up my tris oh my cards are out of order
ah get back in order you silly things you right let me put you back in order trisors first
then it was you then it was you then it was like you then you were my newest addition
are you squidding me right now?
nero!
ryan!
remember the foodies and what are cull on numbers for life
yes yes yes when i lose endless mode i'll go get some food and we'll all get a cup of tea and uh
uh a bit of food to nibble on and then we'll try a difficult deck because now i think i'm on to like
the hard decks now um you know some people like soft decks uh medium henna decks i prefer uh the
hard decks you know you know so they're quite long because there's a lot of cards in them so they can
be quite long decks of them yeah she'll fuck up just fuck up i'm too hyper playing this game with
you because i'm i'm like oh my god a game that i have to use my head but it's kind of working out
oh yeah oh yeah it's all coming together add a playing card not really interested in that
um played cards with clubs not not we will go away
no go away one more okay i will get her because again i love everything thank you again nero for
the pet i get food i promise i get food once we lose because we're gonna lose i'm going to skip
because it gives us another joker i don't know what it's gonna be but uh i'm excited right i can
only play one hand type
yeah i mean i think i'll win anyway oh i should have thrown away the east because
that would have uh that's a freaking million a million swadrillion dollars
whoa played cards give more get in my belly celesteo pack please get in my belly too
who goes there a straight a four of a kind or a straight flush i guess mars
yay wow constellation now does four
tarot cards peer in the shop more actually i'm not really too fast give me my money back
pyramid right now joker bonus lucky blast lucky i guess
yeah lucky i'll take it okay uh and then one reroll for the level up which is good to go
and then go again once dawn trail hits i'm gonna straight for the
and buy for quick what are you in the wrong chat who are you who are you what
there's buy for there's not buy for questions game now here's the hard part we're gonna get
exponential gain yes another negative oh sorry i'm going for the negative go nope i'm just sharing
my day okay that's different then uh i see a duplicate oh wait sorry and a queen
and just like that win i'll read again
this is outrageous
this is outrageous this is streamer lock i'm sorry there's no way you guys are getting
games like this i refuse to believe it give me the hermit crab hermit card sorry no hermit crab
glass diamond spades right perish i'm not doing that give me my hermit card
oh i was joking but i'll take it oh but planet but money but planet though two planets
increase my multiplier it's 4.2 fine take my money it doesn't matter if it's bad because
even even a okay one reroll to boost my other guy and then let's go again
the mark all face all face cards are drawn
but that doesn't matter because i can't read
am i i think i'm gonna hit this like easy stop i'm still winning
oh my god is this the rush that real gamble people feel
okay we're gonna buy you because i don't mind that i like to leave out sure
tarot celestial
uh urinus and you come
oh we're down 4.5 and then a tarot give me my money back give me the hermit
yes oh no again it makes me make a decision between the planets
ah fine you win just this time
a rush aren't you getting desensitized from all the winning no then you guys like play the same game over
that's not even that's not even a realistic jump in endless mode that's not even realistic
come on seven million yeah i don't think we're hitting those either
that's silly come on that's so silly what i need
i need to throw these away i guess you're such a silly game
um
like you're gonna need to give me something yeah fuck it double my money right now yeah
fuck it give me my money i paid for it go
oh seven million i mean
seven million that's such unfair scaling
they were not messing around being like oh yeah no sorry when we said scale we meant
to kale how are my aces and jacks oh i have like no aces okay get rid of that i have seven kings
i have three jacks a bit unlikely eights i have five sevens i have four four actually i'm not gonna
i've got a pair shout out to all my peers um jack you're giving me a hard time buddy i said
ten i've got four of you nine i've got three of you so you're out
eight i've already got a double of you seven i'd like to hold on to you for a planetarium
i'm out of cards
oh i've done it now i've gone
wow okay it's just an excuse to get food i threw on purpose totally
yeah
brah come on i had six kings sitting what i do throw away a three
and a ten no like the likelihood of me getting something decent is so high the seven i ever
did no like brah fine fuck it play a high card i know you're gonna give me a double
how did i even get anywhere oh for fuck
pain i don't i don't know what to do i mean i've lost i'll just admit it you've lost
no you admit you've lost no fuck you no fuck you wait i don't have any discards left right please
oh nonsense
yeah yeah yeah then you all start trickling in at the same time i get it i get it har har har
very funny yeah you should have showed up earlier we maybe i actually could have won that
yeah yeah yeah defeated by a small blade mobile
play the cards
yeah oh max out the interest per round earning for 10 consecutive raise the cap on interest
earned in each round to 20
what am i gonna do when a run without playing a straight damn straight
when a run on any start run with the crystal ball voucher in two copies of the full wait that's
like so advantageous at the end of each round $2 per hand $1 per discard no interest at all so i
wouldn't actually have to bother with the economy one joker slot but minus a hand start a run
you know what we'll give magic a go how about that right let me go for a pee um can't beat
the peeler allegations honestly um let me go for a tinkle i'm gonna make another cup of tea
i'm gonna get some food and then we'll give this one a shot because right now we have see the uh
this wee poker one two three and then we don't have anything else but that doesn't matter we're
working on it okay it's taking it's it's taking a little bit of time um okay but everyone please go
get food please do stretch please stand up and um we'll give one more run to the magic deck um
and i'll see how i'm feeling because i was up quite late um working on like patreon audio so
yeah uh there's two early access patreons if you're interested it's just early access so you
will get to hear it at a later date but one of them i can't upload until 90 days after my warning
is away because i had the audacity to breathe in the audio and i'm like is this too sensitive for
youtube because youtube and breathing right now is getting a bit silly with asmr i really hope
they actually go back on it but i don't know how likely that is um but yeah
peeler how dare you how dare you i know how dare a woman breathe honestly okay i very quickly go
think i'm gonna uh boil the kettle take me only four minutes and you know i'm taking a minute to
sit down on the toilet do you want do you want to detailed so i sit down on the toilet and i think
about you and i just release and that's disgusting i'm so sorry everything never is not the time for
such um for such nefarious activities okay i'll be back in a minute okay please get some um wee
snacky food or um wheat juice or hydration and make sure you stretch your leg okay rather than
sitting for a whole second i'll be right back
so
.